connect waiting for it to connect
waiting for it to connect I think we
have connected I think we have connected
I think we'll finally live we're live on
the YouTubes are we live on the YouTube
channel
[Music]
oh we live on the YouTube the YouTubes
too but we live are we live let me know
you gotta say something in the chat guys
if we're live otherwise it's just gonna
be all this otherwise great song uh
you know as actually there's a great
retrospective on that song and the art
and Blue Swede who made it by Todd in
the shadows y'all should go watch it
what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation Greg and John here today
we are here to do a live streams for the
talk for Guardians of the Galaxy volume
threats is the audio okay
um I mentioned it koi is out of the
country right now he is running from the
law he's actually with I don't know if I
can say what he's doing I don't know if
I'll get in trouble
but it's a good thing it's not it's not
a bad thing it's a good thing it's a
good thing it's a it's a yeah it's a
family trip Yeah man so um a lot of
great things for koi right now so he's
gone so he will not be uh over talking
and dominating the conversation John
might actually get a word in today we'll
see I'm gonna berate uh some people who
aren't tolerant to various other people
it's gonna be great don't worry never
say all the koi stuff I
alrighty guys well uh you guys know how
the drill goes here uh you guys are the
big part of what helps us uh you know
Drive The Narrative of this entire live
stream of where our conversations end up
going right now in the chat spam I want
from one to ten one to one to ten spam
what your number is is it eight out of
ten is it nine out of ten is it five out
of ten spam it in the chat right now
that would be amazing secondly after
you're done spamming go ahead leave a
like
and thirdly thank you guys so much
Hoover here in our last stream
um that one I believe was koi and I and
then we ended up getting so many so many
super chats and streamlabs that we were
live for a much longer than we
anticipated and that's a great thing to
have this good position to be in this
whatever a YouTuber wants to be in when
they go live look at these ratings look
at the ratings for the Guardians of the
Galaxy volume three two three sevens but
mostly just nines tens nines and a halfs
eights eighths and a half's that's good
everyone's enjoying it that's amazing my
God look at this we got eight out of
tens nine out of tens I think the MCU is
back on track yep so we don't have
anything to worry about for the future
whatsoever look at that that's amazing
I'm glad so many people are enthusiastic
it's been a while I'm happy to hear it
guys I know we already got some super
thank you guys who already contributed
to the super chest we will get to every
we never end a stream without going over
every single Super Chat and streamline
never no matter what even if we're
running late to something but John what
would you give it out of 10. oh man
right I feel a little foolhardy saying a
10 out of 10 but I'll give it like a
solid nine you know I at least had a lot
of stuff that I thought was really
terrific and even the things that you
could tighten up about it didn't really
detract that much for me just in light
of everything else they were able to
achieve so like this is quite an
experience and I loved it both times
that's amazing to hear not gonna ask me
what I thought what did you think don't
worry I don't need attention I wanted to
build the suspense to get to your rating
because everyone wants to know your
rating most of all I'm a nine out of 10.
okay I'm probably like a 9.5 out of 10.
good all right yes keeping in our in our
standard tradition alrighty guys okay
let's see here I don't wanna I don't
want to mess this up all right because
we have such a habit of messing this up
so really quick I'm just gonna make sure
we get like the first wow thank you so
much for the event
um John did you do research on the post
credit scene
the girl who they got on can you guys
explain who the chat who that was I
looked it up and I was like I don't
think I'm gonna remember this with the
amount of sleep I'm gonna get John come
on man little girl come on
who is she is she is she she must be I
know she's got the purple eye and she's
got that sort of power stone-ish power
but uh
part of the OG team from the comics X
says in the chat uh
ah lovely okay all righty guys look I'm
gonna kick this off with one thing uh
right away before we get to any super oh
my God thank you so much it's for John
being live last time we got a hundred
dollars thank you so much for that such
a massive Super Chat last time we got
one coin after 100 and we made jokes
that it's because you weren't there I
was dead and now this is now he's now
he's back to to right the wrong
um so the first thing I want to talk
about uh really quick is Adam Warlock
and the reason why I want to talk about
Adam Warlock is because John and I were
talking about this yesterday is that
a lot of times for people who are
walking out of this movie having uh
being a little bit down on it or maybe
not being so in love with it like
everyone's opinion is valid okay
everyone's opinion is valid and I
noticed a common thing that was
happening especially with people were
just talking to off camera and then
sometimes I would watch YouTube videos
again not going after anyone I know it's
a common thing that some people would
often talk about had to do twofold with
what brought the movie down a lot for
them and this seemed to be the main
thing they would talk about instead of
talking about any of the things that
really worked for them and it was an
interesting experience to discuss
because for me I was like well actually
I I even addressed the Adam Warlock
possible issue so what do you get what
are you guys first off I want to ask
were you guys satisfied with what they
did with Adam Warlock in the chat uh let
me know what you guys thought here and
yeah we got a good amount of answers I
hope you hope you're really taking all
the notes right now I hope Marvel's
history that Canon also known as Quasar
she's got similar powers to Captain
Marvel a live spitball [__] about
Adam Warlock opinions most certainly all
right thanks John I'll just talk over
you with all this file available I'm
going to bring this back around to be
like oh John what'd you learn in the
meantime while I was spitballing 100 you
got it but what I was but a lot of
things what people say is like high
evolutionary they'd added they weren't a
big fan of the way his interpretation
went down that a lot of times he just
ended up being a villain who just kind
of kept yelling and I even kind of said
that especially on my first viewing uh I
said on a non-spoiler review and Adam
Warlock I thought had a great
introduction
um but I understand that you know a lot
of people were kind of let down by his
interpretation and that seems to be the
two most common things I hear of what
why people have take fault with this
movie is those two things and I really
feel like that's not the majority of the
film and so to me I'm like that's pretty
much the only two criticism that we
might end up leaning into but there's
something that I feel like a lot of
people don't really look into with Adam
Warlock that I think is really powerful
about his introduction because I've had
this conversation with a lot of people
and none of them ever seem to really
think about this side of the the
conversation with Adam Warlock was that
I love his introduction for yeah how
menacing he is how powerful he is I
think it's like a real scary violent
threat in the beginning but what I think
is really cool about why another reason
that adds to the list of why I think
Guardians 3 is is a perfect conclusion
to the James Gunn Trilogy even factoring
an Infinity war and end game is that
what happens in the beginning is because
of the consequences of what rocket did
in Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 2. like I
re at the end of the day I really felt
like rocket did not really
suffer the most consequences I mean sure
like it led to the if he didn't do what
he did you know
um uh yondu wouldn't probably wouldn't
have died right in the Nova Corps
wouldn't come after them and all that
yeah um but I really but the birth of
Adam Warlock was led to that a big part
of that was because of the situation
that rocket himself landed him in with
stealing the batteries and Guardians too
so I think it's really cool to start
this movie off with the birth of
something that is also the consequences
of Rocket's actions as well which I
think is like a powerful way to get it
going but then granted throughout the
movie I sort of felt like Adam Warlock
while funny and I was always amused but
on my second viewing I was going
I could see a version where you didn't
need him in this movie yeah you could
cut him out with little consequence and
then you just have to figure out how a
couple uh of the more magical you know
you'd have to figure out how to save
certain people without him but yeah I I
I personally enjoyed the arc that they
gave him and the sort of like you're
watching this child this ostensible
child in the body of a man you know sort
of learn how to be a real person and
butting up against all the different
ideologies that are forced upon him and
uh yeah I found him quite enjoyable both
times really however I can't really deny
that if you removed him and not a lot
would change I think I think Will
Poulter does a great job of yeah I think
he could have been fleshed out a little
bit better or could have been a main
villain there's a lot of different ways
you could have done something with him I
thought in the beginning I'm like wow
this is amazing what they're doing with
him and then he does become kind of
funny my my concern for him moving
forward in the future is that they might
do a Thor love and thunder situation
where it's like oh he's part of this new
set of the Guardian audience then he
just leaves after like five minutes yeah
he's like has an existential crisis and
he's like all stoically
seriously my own way yeah yeah it's my
introduction of Warlock and I really
don't know much about him um you know in
the comments the first main thing I read
of him was when I read The Infinity
Gauntlet comic and it was such a
prevalent part of that uh and he he
would have been uh he would have you
know probably really helped out with
preventing the snap situation from going
on well that's what he's great and I'm
excited to still see more from the
future well and I guess I would put it
to you guys like is that something that
factors into your overall perception of
the character in this movie because
especially with that knowledge that he
would be so in you know in the comics
and whatnot and in other interpretations
he is so instrumental in the fight
against Thanos then seeing him here in a
capacity that isn't all so super
instrumental to this movie probably
feels like you're being slighted like if
he had shown up in this and been like
the main presence or something or the
main secondary presence I wonder if
people might feel a little different but
let's get back to this positives here
guys guys
what was your favorite part about who's
your favorite character in this movie
it's probably gonna be rocket who's your
favorite character your favorite
non-rocket let's go with who's your
favorite character in this movie that
was not Rocket Raccoon personally I
didn't think I'd be saying this it was
Star-Lord for me I really love star lord
and I feel like Chris press actually
we're really not getting enough credit
for his performance here yeah I gotta
say I feel like it was starlord both
times I watched it I'm like if it's not
Rocky I think I'm going with Star-Lord
here sure sure absolutely uh I honestly
was everyone's so great nebula was
terrific I almost am tempted to say
nebula just because I love the growth
that her character has gone on but
mantis I thought was was so lovely and
terrific and and the fact that they push
her so hard out of her sweet and lovely
comfort zone uh I I appreciate it even
though people have critiqued this movie
for you know a lot of people getting
into yelling matches and stuff like that
like I don't know especially when mantis
does it it's like whoa who you must be
super upset
um but yeah I don't know I I I I I loved
the life they brought God you see what
I'm living in this chat when I asked
that question it they're hopping between
all of them yeah nebula was amazing
nebulous terrific did you guys think
nebula was going to die when she put I
thought they were good but this movie
did such a lot of people are a little
bit um
surprise I mean honestly I'm surprised
that no one died in this movie and
what's up there were the movie did such
an excellent job though creating tension
and Stakes when you think characters are
going to die like I would forget about
oh yeah we didn't see that moment in the
trailer yet you know like the first
thing we saw in the trailer was a scene
when Drax throws the ball at that uh
animal girl when they land on camera
child yeah that's the first thing you
see and then when Drax gets shot on that
planet that they break into or that uh
prison system in the orgosphere yeah
when when he gets horoscope when he gets
shot
it really looks like oh this is it this
is when Dave Batista dies in The
Guardians of the Galaxy franchise
completely forgot like oh yeah there's
this whole other scene in the trailer
that we still have not got into and they
could really capture that harrowing
aspect of it
um I thought was excellent Star-Lord
I was talking with John about this just
last night if they did not immediate if
they did not five minutes before that
moment when Star Lord's in space and his
and his face is starting to like you
know he's gonna load from within space
yeah all of his fluids traveling to his
head if they didn't have five minutes
before Adam Warlock get like being told
everyone deserves a second chance I
would not have expected Adam Warlock to
step in but because of that I was like
oh okay he's not going to add him more
so I heard people in the theater going
what no I was one of those people the
first time like I was I was I was it's
the magician's slight I was so consumed
by like oh man his face is like to me
they sold me on like even if somebody
comes and gets him I mean I feel like
the damage is already done but you know
yeah that's the Sci-Fi for you
um and then nebula when she's the one
who just who was the last power of the
ship yeah yeah I thought oh my God nebul
is about to die yeah yeah I thought that
was like I'll go down and you guys get
out of here or whatever but I never
believe even when we were doing the
trailer reactions and stuff never really
rocket would die I feel from watching
Guardians one to his whole journey it
was like no he deserves a happy ending
and that's kind of the whole purpose to
live a life otherwise this movie's just
mean yeah
even some people were pointing out
Gamora like I thought she was terrific
in this as well and for as different as
her character has to be and the point of
it being so different like I thought she
handled it really I've heard some people
critique about war Pig was going to die
I was uh yeah Tim's talking bringing up
a great chat the second time watching
yeah I was like wait a minute where's
your freaking man where did Peter's did
I can't remember in the Guardians and
Guardians 2 was it destroyed in his
fight with ego I I really don't remember
but I also feel like it's been a few
years
they've got enough means no I have not
watched the breakdown new rock stars uh
really quick I do want to catch up on
the on the super chats but I appreciate
what everyone's saying in this chat I'm
already loving it let's get into some
really specific stuff what do you think
about the creep scene oh that's great I
and I mean a great I thought this might
be my favorite soundtrack of the three
and using creep especially I think is a
perfect way to kick things off because
in their own way all these characters
feel like Creeps and Weirdos and wonder
what the hell they're doing here and I
feel like that song gets dogged anyway
so this was a nice application for me
well I think using the songs too as
bookends for the movie where you have
one song that has a much more dour song
and then the other one
because the Guardians movies start off
you know not like instantaneously
there's usually like an opening tease
and then they've gone to like a dance
number and this movie does not have a
dance number at the beginning and then
to end it with the dance number that
feels very real and not this like hyper
choreographed edit it just feels like
people like having a real like
sentimental nostalgic moment a
celebration moment well yeah genuine
like you can feel like the camera's just
capturing people on a dance floor I had
this moment at both times where I was
like I've seen so many of this kind of
scene in movies where like people get
together and dance especially like fam
movies and it's fun it's like I'm not
ever gonna like poo poo that but this
was one of the few times where I was
like I feel the worth and value of
having this sequence because like after
all that we've been through like the joy
of just being together and dancing and
especially just like in in the further
I've gotten along in life The more I've
started to Value just yeah like the joy
of Letting Go and dancing with people
and just like the the beauty of that and
so like yes I'm a super cathartic all
right guys bear me for one minute I'm
gonna make some adjustments here while
we play some catch up on some super
chats um we got a t-shirt right now so
thank you guys so much but let me just
adjust this
let's do this we gotta we got a new way
of you know wrong one wrong one I found
a new way
I found a new way to read your super
chats all right I just gotta remember I
just need to do a refresher on my Noggin
of how I did this before so there we go
anyone's Chats on screen oh boom John's
good times you even got more space to
move us up so we can see even more Super
Chat action
it's better to just keep it one at a
time John I know I'm just saying you got
like a bunch of black space at the top
that you could fill up with our
beautiful faces
this is this is like when Greg's making
a thumbnail and he can't [__] figure
it out yeah you should start live
streaming your thumbnail making process
just to so people can see what it's like
do you guys like the high evolutionary
part of the John John of the thumb isn't
that hilarious ah I'm the blackest
person at the real Rejects
I was gonna do me but I was like this is
John's moment yes to scream and abuse
animals it's definitely John's moment
that's right that's me the high hum
solutionary why do we have black screen
what why do we have more of that black
screen at the top John you know what's
going on there just move it up
it's just there's more plane to be
filled there you go oh interesting yeah
you just have more space Oh my God look
at that guys look how beautiful this
looks everyone gets a chance to shine
and be on the live stream everybody
lives your comments the super chat's
Gonna Shine look how amazing this is
that's my one contribution you should
take over don't you ever do that again
two questions John and now we can read
it on the actual main screen instead of
looking to our left and hurting our
necks
yes two questions since the movie ended
with Star-Lord will return but not
Guardians at the Galaxy C3 but not card
is the Galaxy
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 will not
return and then how do you think he will
return
um if Quentin Tarantino did an MCU movie
then what would the movie be about wow
those are two very very you were abusing
the Super Chat system here
um I think Tarantino would only do a
movie about Luke Cage first of all I
think it would be really cool if they
actually did bring him by doubt he would
ever do it I feel like this final foam
really will be his last film because
he's a interesting individual that way
um I think Star-Lord I think the plan is
to really wait for him to return in in
like
Dynasty or Secret Wars I don't think
we'll see him back until then I don't
feel like he's gonna have like a so what
would his solo I mean he can't have
souls
yeah and taking care of him showing us
what the Health Care system does to our
elders I will say you know the part of
it though that I am a little bit
concerned about while I think the um the
the discrepancy I'll keep this really
short what time is it okay right there
all right so it's one two two all right
John so uh the part of it that I'm a
little concerned about with the
Guardians characters uh proceeding
forward is the fact that James Gunn's
not going to be doing the writing like
while I think the handling of them was
pretty good for the most part in an
Infinity War you know they're James Gunn
really pushed back on the whole thing
about um he does not believe that
Star-Lord would have actually
um messed up the whole plan with
punching Thanos and then you know get
contributing to like what happened with
the universe yeah and to me like oh that
is such a Monumental like that's a
massive character moment for Star-Lord
and James going to bohemianly disagreed
with that yeah and to me I'm like uh you
know there such a particular kind of
writing that goes for them and and
obviously even with a movie like volume
three
his love for these characters really
shines through so I'm not particularly
excited about seeing them return without
James Gunn yeah I would have to agree
with that not that anybody couldn't do
it but you know I mean like the Russo
brothers are heavily revered as being
like the greatest Marvel filmmakers and
that was a decision made under their
watch so you know I feel like yeah these
characters in particular as portrayed by
these actors it would be hard to find
somebody unless I don't know if if James
Gunn gave his Blessing to a particular
writer or whatever who he thinks has the
voice but yeah I would be trepidatious
at the very least that I don't know
exactly what a solo Star-Lord outing
would look like and I I kind of like the
idea of letting things rest you know for
a minute because especially once people
leave like you know it's like we let
Robert Downey Jr go and then pretty soon
it was like when's he coming back how
are we gonna get him back and I'm like
let's let Star Wars Lord be out there
and do his thing and if they tease that
they must have some level of a plan but
yeah I would hope that it's not at least
for a while yet and probably most likely
in one of those big team up and or
secret uh Invasion events uh yeah okay
Wars I see people are talking about high
evolutionary in the chat we will be
getting to high evolutionary don't you
worry people thank you so much uh
Mustafa job for the question uh AMV
thank you very much force contributing
when I Evol wonders ah smart that's how
you squeeze it in when you get a limited
amount of characters and super chats I
like that uh what high Evolution wonders
why rocket has been alive this long vim
and Theo shared a look behind him do we
know do we know why seen it two times
and can't figure why that's what you're
interviewing yes I'll ask them this
particular question actually yeah you
know what that's a great thing I feel
like the because they have that turn
right which one's vimin Thiel which
one's Vim uh oh
John you're interviewing I think you
better not mess this up John I think Vim
is the lady and feel is the gentle oh
John oh this is a bad look John I know
I'm gonna show them this John that's
right you should show up with the
interviews look he doesn't even know
which one is who
they're similarly looking characters
one's a guy one's a girl John come on I
know and the worst part about the
interview is I don't have any reason to
be like I'm Filipino too because uh feel
it oh John I know fim is the lady
already Nicholas thank you so much thank
you thank you for keeping me honest so
um yeah reporter Vim you're right I mean
I I think Vim
they definitely kept stuff secret I feel
like they had a big that would actually
be a really interesting question asked
um I'm gonna say Vince Vaughn uh Jameson
to ask James Gunn because yeah they she
they do have the turn she does have the
turn on him later in the movie The Mew
today uh but
it's obvious that you know while there's
some scenes that hint towards that
possibly happening I imagine that if
they had information on b298 they
probably
kept it hidden for a while I think they
probably knew some stuff but they kept
it hidden yeah yeah and that's one thing
I'm curious to ask them about is there's
so much in those characters that seems
like it's held under the server like
there's so much they seem like they are
thinking or maybe want to say but don't
and and more so certainly with Vim
obviously given where her story goes but
uh yeah I'm very curious because I don't
think that they would have some kind of
like I don't think they would have
tampered with eight nine p13 on their
own or something like that and you know
had some kind of ulterior plot I don't
think they're quite bold enough for that
but I am curious as to if they you know
have some kind of I don't know excess
piece of context we don't know about or
if they're just worried like I don't
have the answer what do we do you know
because when you got somebody like that
hanging over you who is like so intense
and so result driven it's like if we
don't have an answer we're screwed you
know so
appreciate the breakdown there John that
was solid that was solid breakdown
AMV also follows it up with I'd like to
think High evolved got more unhinged
from his treatments he could have been
on the beta protein that rocket
discovered made batch 90 violent
I don't know he was already pretty
unhinged yeah he seems like he's been on
hinges this whole time he was already a
total the thing that led to Rocket
attacking him was the fact of how
diabolical the guy already was I mean
that's a nice Theory to have uh I mean
I'm sure I'm sure I I mean I'm sure it's
suffering the infliction of violence
that rocket delivered him which is that
that scene when Lila and and um and
floor and teeth die that scene as
heartbreaking as it is
it's interesting one of the things I
love about James Gunn I don't agree with
the assessment that you know this movie
can totally conflict I don't
um I think that scene is one of the
powerful Parts about that scene is it
has this one moment in there when rocket
put it simple plain simple [__] up you
know High evolutionary space and it's
very violent like it's pretty disturbing
imagery especially for a PG-13 movie A
Rob Zombie
so he [__] up his face and in that
moment you're like yeah but also right
before that
and and that right before that and after
that it's heartbreaking because Lila
died and his other two friends died as
well so I think that's one of the
powerful Parts about James Gunn
filmmaking is you can have both at the
same time as awesome as it is to be like
yeah but you want to see High
volitioner's face get messed up and know
that it was at Rocket's hands it's also
really disturbing to see what rocket did
at the same time because that is his
First Act of real violence and then the
first time he's like picking up a gun I
think that's a really powerful scene you
know and I know a lot of people have
issues with the darkness of this movie
uh but to me I feel like the darkness is
well well earned yeah and it's hinted at
for so long you know like it's it's
clearly a part of Rocket's history and
that's one of those few moments where
that like that delivers you a catharsis
that is hard to attain in real life I
would say
uh Leah I love your question thank you
for the Super Chat what is your ranking
of all three films and holidays holiday
special
you know I feel like it's unfair to rank
the holiday special against
uh three one two
I like to a lot more upon revisiting it
um but I think 312 would probably be the
order I enjoy the most
I just don't know if I've seen one too
many times now where
approximity so funny we've obviously
been reading your super chats I mean
you're obviously been reading that your
normal chat
um but um the the oh God that's hard I I
think recency bias can definitely play a
factor in my own Noggin and a lot of
times I can have a different opinion
when it's like I watch it at home versus
being in the theaters you know and so I
it's difficult for me to say
I feel like I probably have the same
ranking as you right now I feel like
three yeah three to me is the most sort
of meaningful and three three is so
satisfying in that it brings everything
around it really feels like it's
connected to the other two movies it
makes both of the previous ones more
rich and uh and yeah I don't know just
like the level of emotionality you get
out of this journey and the amount of
just attention paid to every character's
growth I think is really beautiful
well okay Lionheart you're saying I'd
like two more than one and that's the
weird thing I kind of like two more than
one when I re-watched the movies
recently I don't know if it's because I
was just hit with the feeling of oh my
God I finally get this movie and I
really like it
um so I don't know if it was just
because I was over I was I was over it
was at Danny DeVito meme from It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia right
that's where I got hit with was that
feeling of I finally understand this and
I think that made me just fall in love
with it even more
and uh that one does bring me to tears
so I'm not sure I really don't know I'm
not a big fan of ranking because I feel
like my rankings just change all the
time yeah well that's the other thing
yeah uh but I do I do really I love
Guardians too a lot I I love all three
of these films and the holiday special
too like I it's my favorite franchise
within the MCU well and I wanna I wanna
now it's having Scene Three go back and
re-watch two at least again just to see
how much more it might gain from this
experience because too like like you
said so much of what happens with rocket
and that story is paid off here that's
what I think is also great about this
being a volume like I really look at the
words of volume more than just the play
on the music side of it uh I do look at
it as like some people feel like Groot
does not get enough attention here but
I'm like yeah well Groot had a big part
of volume one and then baby Groot and
then I am Groot you know like like his
story has been served already and then
he was even part of you know making
um
you know John you could just you and koi
just never wait sorry
I'm just gonna go in
geez I'm gonna let a big old silence go
next time just for you it would have
been two seconds
you get there all the time you do and
I'm waiting to binge Barry oh
that's a fun one
um and no I haven't I don't have you
seen anything met someone if we see
Madagascar never see Madagascar maybe
one day
no I'm RC charm we totally talked about
Adam Warlock at the beginning of this
uh we will talk about that I love you
guys in a second let's see AMV
uh I cried thank you so much I cried
every time they showed floor sure poor
thing was maimed and full of Innocence
especially when she was saying thief's
floor rocket go now repeatedly yeah I oh
I don't know about you okay what is it
all right 32. I don't know about you but
on my second time watching I did find it
a little ham-fisted on the first two
flashbacks with the friends of how it is
just like noise diet friends at least
like it's kind of like Disney Channel
writing with them in that moment that
that particularly break your heart yeah
that particular line is like a is I mean
yeah that's what it's there for it's
it's there to make you go ah [__] this
is kind of come back and it's gonna come
back in a very hurtful way and uh and
yeah it's good to have friends it's
about the purest thing you could
possibly say like I buy it because the
characters are so pure and because their
scope is so limited but also I'm like
that is a direct tug on the heartstring
yeah but the chaos of that moment and
yeah like that that whole yelling like
rug you know the chief's rocket floor go
now and just she keeps repeating it like
the the amount of Chaos and and just
volume and overlapping voices and panic
that ensues in that situation I thought
was really unsettling and affecting
uh rocket is definitely the best
Guardian member of it sure oh I do but
the scene when they all uh come together
in the heaven scene
that that moment is just absolutely
beautiful like that's a kind of common
scene that happens in a lot of films and
[__] where they like go to heaven for a
minute but they're not your time yet
then they pushed it back down
that's what I'm that's got to be one of
my all-time favorite
versions of doing that kind of scene
yeah especially because they dream so
much of going to the sky you know
getting to see the outside world and
then and then for her to validate rocket
by being like you were right oh my God
it's beautiful it really was beautiful
and to know that the MCU has some sort
of Heaven is also nice I mean you could
also argue that it's just the visions of
a Dying creature but also I don't know I
like the idea that maybe they are out
there sorry this is where sometimes you
don't read every comment out loud here
because we know they're in a Super Chat
and they're like which is fantastic yeah
we will answer it again but more
efficiency yeah don't worry pandemic
we'll do a whole secondary breakdown
yeah
um Johnny got lost thank you Johnny got
lost movie had me balling when rock baby
rocket said hurts I know
they make him so like I I love the way
they realize his speech he's like so
monosyllabic at the beginning
my my wife we like it my wife is hyper
sensitive towards animal cruelty animal
deaths very very sensitive learn my
lesson
that sort of things
and I became a for anyone who says this
movie does not have political commentary
doesn't know what the [__] they're
talking about all right uh and some of
you guys might know what I'm talking
about right animal rights but there are
people who who are like thank you for
not doing a movie that doesn't have
political commentary Marvel and you made
something I'm like this movie is filled
with political commentary and just
because it's not talking about female
empowerment or representation does not
mean there's not political commentary in
it plain and simple yeah
um
responding to is well handled
thematically motivated politics versus
politics shoved in
yeah exactly
like it's insane the romantic story
isn't forced to happen at the end you
know like well all sorts of things but
the main I'm sorry the main
but consists of this film but yeah it's
all about like animal rights yeah animal
like there's some terrible things that
happen to it the animals in real life
um but anyway
my uh my wife so sensitive and then and
then in the beginning of the movie
I wasn't bringing it out because you're
super chat Johnny got lost at the very
beginning of the movie
uh when you do go to Rocket like the hot
the the what a beautiful haunting first
opening shot
with seeing it from baby Rocket's
perspective of the high evolutionary's
hands in slow motion this like it is
like an evil God yeah you know like
seeing it in the darkness seeing baby
rockets seeing um uh High evolutionary
the way high evolutionary sort of wants
to be seen yeah
when she started crying in that opening
moment I went
okay so when that scene comes because I
saw it before she said once before she
did I was like I'm definitely walking
around at the theater yeah
scene happens I'm like I'm just walking
you out I'm gonna tell you what happens
it's tremendous and then we're gonna go
back in there all right yeah totally and
you timed that very well yeah I was like
she needs the one part to see with the
key getting it made then we're leaving
yeah yeah exactly and I love the way
they put that in too little he's
stealing little pieces throughout all
right here we go
pandemic Jones oh man if I just waited
one second
um thank you pandemic one of our top
one of our top things animal cruelty is
much of a political view because so many
of the products that we make in America
and around the world is based off of
animal cruelty they do a lot of animal
experimentations even with like vaccines
and stuff are clothing the skin care
products genetics yeah yeah there's a
lot of animal cruelty that goes on that
a lot of people are just not aware of
and there's so much waste that happens
behind closed doors
um to make Humanity better that's the a
big part of the commentary pandemic
Jones uh this was your story you just
didn't know it yet has got to be one of
the best lines of the MCU I will
probably have more thoughts coming haha
uh yeah John what do you think online
take it away it was lovely and I I mean
you know it's certainly it's obvious for
part three but as I think it pertains to
the entirety of the franchise and yeah I
mean I think that is that is something
that well I mean yeah it's in a lot of
ways a Star Wars star-lord's story as
well uh yeah I mean like the amount of
just you know hinting at what's going on
with the rocket and Rocket being such an
emotional core throughout them yeah that
was a lovely way to tie that off and a
lovely way to like make a a Trilogy
within a bigger franchise have its own
arc in terms of like Shifting the focus
around and and doing that in a way that
feels natural and and yeah I thought
that was uh really nicely handled and a
nice sort of gift after all the anguish
yeah
how was star-lord's face able to get
repaired another interesting question I
mean they must have put one of those Med
packs on it but at the same time I'm
just like how did you not die from that
like I don't know like what I would love
to as much as I don't care for the whole
like Neil deGrasse like well if it's not
100 scientifically accurate it's not
good kind of like POV I'm still like I
want to know the science of this
yeah Adam Driver casted for Reed Richard
and Fantastic Four for real
um I I feel like
it was pretty much confirmed already and
now it's just now it's just actually now
it's just doubly confirmed I found a guy
in the internet who does a good Adam
Driver talked about it a couple weeks
ago and and uh so yay I'm happy uh
that's good let's do it I think he's a
great actor he's a good actor it's one
of the best maybe we'll get Margot
Robbie next and I feel like because some
people might not want to hear this but I
feel like because it's MCU might get a
chance to Showcase re display Adam
drivers
um humor again oh I think he's one of
them no more humor in the MC I think
he's one of the best SNL celebrity hosts
that's ever grace that television show
oh yeah Luke dent04 guys I want you to
know that you are uh riding here and
there's a writer's record today for my
birthday love from the ukai uh thank you
Luke dent and happy birthday to you man
what a dark but joyful birthday present
I suppose you know sometimes birthdays
they make you think of mortality and so
does a movie like this it ties in uh
yeah happy birthday man go have yourself
a dance party and reconnect with your
grandpa hey seriously thank you guys to
everyone who's been contributing to the
super chassis and thank you guys so much
for being in this stream uh you know
like it's always more fun to do these
when we really love the movie versus
like [__] we're gonna be arguing we
should sometimes be a more fun stream
but you know all right yeah each one is
uh its own special thing
let me see here all right but John love
quantumania I thought it was decently
fun the third time
I like ants
I just I love that give me more silly
ass hankman I wish I wish the super
chats could be uh not the Super Chat so
it's just on the live chat yeah you
could
um get rid of the typing bar the crop
bar this part right here
let me let me may I with your permission
High evolutionary uh attempt a tweet I
think this movie wanted to be rated R
but didn't but while you're doing that
I'm going to read the Super Chat from
green drink
I feel the last post-credits scene uh
thank you for the super chat last post
credit scene uh talking about the
Grandpa's stepson was odd like they cut
something out last minute given that the
mother was also African-American do you
think Jonathan Majors was originally a
part of it not all black people are
related uh
I know you're saying that's the neighbor
he's talking about across the street is
it's just Kang sitting on the porch of
Peter mow the lawn that's the variant
yeah on Earth 616. yeah he's just a
slacker who makes people it's Grandpa's
lawn
um Daniel Richards is a [__] bum
616. uh yeah that last post credit scene
no I think it was just made for joking
purposes honestly I I think that was
yeah some people are reading into it
that it could be something more but at
the same time you know James Gunn this
is him saying goodbye and I think he was
just capturing like a family moment for
four star that's my that's my take as I
know it's not as cool of like an MCU you
know thing of like we're really teasing
something massive to come I I know it's
not as cool as that uh to me it is just
a a human conversation between the two
of them off of catching up and it's just
a it's kind of like a slice of Life
moment for them and to me that's all it
was was like this is Star-Lord got what
he wanted at the end that's part that's
his journey in ARCA because so much of
this movie is about acceptance yeah and
and especially being accepting of your
of where you come from and that doesn't
have to dictate who you are now but
being okay with where you come from and
then looking at who you are today and
being okay with that and I think that's
what that move that final post credit
scene represents personally
I don't feel like there's anything to
whoever that other guy is yeah but I
know some people were like maybe maybe
yeah
yeah totally I I you know I think yeah I
would have to agree because especially
seeing it the second time at first I
thought the implication was slightly
different but no I I think it's just
yeah it's just he's home and we've seen
him home in a chaotic way through these
movies and now we see him at home in you
know the the peaceful sort of human way
totally forgot guys
been wearing the shirt and this is a
real rejects exclusive space baby shirt
at shopzeroedition.com totally forever
just wear it this whole time and I'm
should probably mentioned plug here
that's the plug I'll plug it again leave
a like on this video
um yeah
I like that no one died that's that'd be
painful James gonna love his characters
too much was that was that was that a
mother or was that like his caretaker I
wasn't clear on who the woman was
pretty sure that's his wife is it he got
remarried and he said his mother his son
her son it's her son
oh who's who's Melania Simo
no her son's the one who's outside
watching
I thought it was oh that's not his son
I thought it was the son of the neighbor
Whose Line he's supposed to mow because
that's he should do it I thought he was
neighbors I thought he was saying hearse
I thought he was saying her son not
unless she's their neighbor that's
that's why I was like did he marry her
socks so low in that line I don't know
no yeah because the first time that I
thought it was something more along
those lines than the second time it was
just like no it's just like this woman
across the street needs her lawn mode
her son is gonna sit out there and watch
me do it he should do it you know like
uh oh yeah yeah but uh but yeah I mean
like it was cool and and it was a nice
device of like oh maybe I'm at the wrong
house but I was just like who is this
woman I want to know
Alistair
McDonald
hey proximo we already said that at the
very very very very very very beginning
of the stream Alastair McDonald first
live viewing we could read it here why
do I keep doing that habit John first
live viewing from Inverness Scotland hey
love you guys just make my work day so
much easier I like the movie but thought
some of the humor was a bit first at
points
I I guess I can understand that the the
more jokey jokes they make sense for the
voice of the characters and they've
always kind of been there but you know
the times where you know you got drag
stepping in like oh are we pretending to
be mad again like you know certain
things like that are a little obvious
but I still found them Charming here
like I thought two had more humor that
didn't feel as coalescent uh as one or
three
yeah I think when it comes to the MCU
they especially get dogged if a joke
doesn't land yeah even though a lot of
the time the jokes will land yeah
because I'm like at the end of the day
one of it's uh adjacent genres is comedy
uh for Guardians of the Galaxy it's a
hundred percent uh so there's gonna be
jokes that are really funny and there's
going to be jokes that don't land and
then if they don't land
it might feel forced or it's just the
joke
I think the good thing is they always
feel in care it's like the thing about
arguing like over the sofa and
everything is like well that's indrax's
character so even if you don't find this
especially hilarious it still makes
sense that they would be bickering about
all these things I do think that
sometimes
the yelling of the Guardians becomes a
bit too much it's a very yelly movie
everyone's very pent up in this becomes
a bit Rob zombie-ish sure
where it's a yelling family yeah yeah
John take it away thank you for such a
generous Super Chat thank you so much I
am glad to be back and I did it all for
you ajb I didn't want to talk to anybody
else in fact I was hoping that you
specifically would be here so that we
can have a one-on-one dialogue just
about the things that we loved about
this movie and then maybe later we can
meet up and paint each other's bodies
gold and uh do you know some kind of
little erotic Adam Warlock sort of play
together so that's that's what I was
hoping for today so if you're down I
mean this is the perfect way to begin a
beautiful friendship A Beautiful Romance
and uh maybe one day we can go out and
uh you know help some people do some
good putting together a team maybe do
some good I think it's got something to
do with Spider-Man
and you maybe love you buddy seriously
though thank you for the the incredibly
generous assistant yeah thank you so
much thank you thank thank you warmed my
cockles uh what I okay making some notes
Here on things I want to make sure we
touch on so I'm gonna say the hallway
fight High evolutionary face reveal I
thought you were race reveal at first I
was like high evolutionary race reveal
well he is black wow is he related to
Jonathan
is he related to Roadie is he related to
Maria Rambo
um the F-bomb I suppose yeah let's go to
the F-bomb Maya knock uh or I don't I
have I have notes here that I'm putting
together I'm putting together a note I'm
putting together some bullet points uh
my knock running
on nav or you know run another dumb
Americans let's go there
um
hi Greg and John hi there what do you
think starlord would appear next which
upcoming upcoming movie TV series
special I think it's just going to be
Avenger Secret Wars uh or Avengers King
Dynasty honestly I mean if we kind of
deep dope into it a little bit he's
going to show up in Kang Dynasty just to
punch King in the face
yeah it's gonna be his whole thing from
now on oh no Star-Lord no no get her boy
he's the real threat we're back in the
real threat of the MCU the whole time
Nick Fury goes to his Grandpa's place
he's like you gotta keep this
[__] under control
all right we're gonna use this as an
opportunity to talk about the hallway
fight scattered brain reviews hey guys
love the movie thank you for the Super
Chat I gotta ask favorite needle drop of
the Guardians Trilogy uh oh what is that
song called Don't
from Brooklyn No Sleep till Brooklyn No
Sleep till Brooklyn
I feel like that's the name of this song
If it's not the name of the song it's
the most recognizable hook No Sleep till
Brooklyn
oh yeah um that was my favorite needle
drop of it because that
had that perfect segue into the this
version of the Guardians really coming
together and then leading into
one of my favorite I've seen a bunch of
the MCU fights multiple times just like
watching on my phone even like watch
this fight again that is one of the best
fights in the MCU hands down easy and
I'm including that amongst the Daredevil
fight scenes because that is such an
amazing and with the way that it's like
edited to the song as well is beautiful
and that's just me using an excuse to
talk about the hallway fight but so with
the hallway fight
um what's so cool about that is
not only are you cutting it's not just
you cut to watch Groot use his powers
watch this person use their powers
you're watching them bounce off of each
other and and sometimes like bouncing on
bouncing out to each other using each
other to get to the bad guys and stuff
they're really working together here and
it feels like they're improvising it
along the way and it's just such
beautiful choreography and some of the
coolest Maneuvers we've seen any of them
do and it just has such an epic ending
moment with it as well I think and
everyone is awesome as hell everyone is
so awesome in that fight and the camera
work over here following the characters
around but I like I I love when they are
actually even even when like Groot and
Star-Lord are working together I noticed
on the second time you'll see moments in
the in that fight when they're taking
out the high leadership people where
he'll go under like groot's legs and
start shooting and stuff like I'm like
that's the kind of [__] that I love
where if you slow it down you can see
even more cool choreography going on
yeah when the the hallway fight is is
like so impressive because I mean not
only do you have the Thematic elements
of everybody getting a moment everybody
working together they off the toughness
but I I just couldn't help but uh I
guess pun intended Marvel at what they
were able to do with that because I
remember people last week were sharing
that one shot from the Transformers
trailer and people being like well yeah
but it's all CGI so like is how
impressed like a great animation sure
but how impressive is that and and to me
I kept sitting there going okay this is
ostensibly a one shot it's not it has to
be stitched together because of all
these effects however the way they were
able to like really balance out their
practical and physical elements it's
like at one point you got mantis
swinging off of groot's arm to kick
somebody and then you've got that one
bit where quill does the roll as he's
sticking the little uh electric uh the
electrocution nodes on people and it's
like you've got this you can tell it's
him too you can tell it's like rolling
yeah yeah and it's like they're using
these wide angle lenses which I imagine
already presents a different kind of
challenge to a scene like this but even
further than that it's like yeah you've
got these stunts and what I realized too
is that you also have the camera
changing speed in mid shot where you can
tell they had to change the frame rate
in camera to achieve this effect like
you know when it in certain moments
where Star Lord's action slows down and
then picks back up and it's like wow and
like the physical elements Drax stabs
that guy up against the thing and he
falls down pinned by his leg like nebula
moment the nebula moment where and so
many times where she gets like all yeah
warped and dismantled and then comes
right back it's it's like yeah there's
so many things things happening and yet
it's clear it's kinetic but smooth and
like it really is to me like the epitome
of movie Magic in an action context
because like there are so many gorgeous
effects such great camera choreography
blocking of the actors they all have to
sell the stunts like I was truly Blown
Away by that sequence
um but needle drops I mean to me it's
it's so hard to choose one I guess uh
it's it's either it's either creeper dog
days they're both stupid
we moved on
we did it
Zakaria 69.
thank you did you think starler was
gonna die because at first I was like no
way yeah someone brought it up earlier
in the chat I mean I know we've already
talked about that I didn't think he
would actually die
um but some brought up earlier in the
chat and I and I would have not liked it
if he died in that moment because
for the few who not the few but in the
first time we saw it for a lot of people
who were surrounded by who were like
freaking out that star-lord's about to
die
like I can't remember who was it Wendy
someone was like are you serious I heard
someone say that someone said are you
serious and to me I would have actually
been upset because I thought this is
going a little too it's kind of just
rushed to it yeah so I would not have
liked it if he died and no I did not
believe he was going to die
um I just love that they did God and
Adam you know he comes to get him uh
yeah that's true like it's such a it's
like such a triumphant moment but I'm
also like that is a joke I think is
really well placed because you get it or
you don't
um Alonzo P thank you so much Gamora
nebula reversing this is one of the
things I talked about with John one of
the first times we really discussed it
off uh when a reading didn't want to go
into it in the non-spoiler uh good
morning nebula reversing roles and
having great arcs yeah I think that's
one of the really cool Parts about this
is like
um Gamora
gamorus you know I've heard this going
being said a lot and it honestly can't
be said any better is that this movie
you really do get to see uh Gamora as
the daughter of Thanos you really get
that impression of her it's like yeah
that is the aggressive side of the time
where she's plugged out of but if you
watch like the trajectory of where
nebula was in Guardians one to where she
is now that is like what the Gamora Arc
or was kind of like
um from guardians one to like Guardians
two Infinity War included actually and
now nebula is the one who had that Arc
so to see them be reversed especially
for a bookend of a Trilogy yeah where oh
nebula's like well nebula gets angry you
don't think she's going to be the
rageful
the same way she once was yeah and I
think it's cool that they did have that
flip where they can learn the heart from
each other especially with
um you know because Guardians too they
do have a little like Heart to Heart
moment but I love the Gamora nebula
Journey throughout all all of these you
know and I even think it's cool with
infinity war and end game included how
Infinity War has the Gamora story and
nebula gets her story in end game yeah
and I think a lot of people kind of
Overlook how
how vital to the MCU the Guardians are
and especially the infinity war and end
game right but Infinity War especially
you know so yeah
is there audio too low
we can crank it even higher I don't know
John yells
I'll put my mic way down here
gonna do a little refresher here
everyone just just keep your eyes on the
screen everyone's gonna just check a
couple of things here
John read some comments oh hey uh did
you think that nebulous arms made a
vibranium nanotech uh I mean certainly
some kind of nanote I'm getting tighter
than nanotech honestly but I really
nanotech I really liked the design of
her arm actually I mean I wouldn't be
surprised if it was vibranium or
something similarly as strong and
durable but uh I I liked what they did
with her arm quite a bit and we did rate
the movies at the beginning uh Proxima
Century uh you know what not enough
people are talking about too is her in
the opening with uh nebula with those
like wings fire yeah the beetle effect
that she had yeah that was bad one I
loved two that they have I like their
side of the Galaxy because they do have
certain Tech that is very more
significantly quieter than usual
uh uh what did you do to the stream
everything is is where's your volume at
because everything is those are just our
headphones these are just for the
headphone yeah these are just the
headphone audio see and these are the
actual input audio
and uh yeah I don't know I can just
crank you up to the top I'm sorry
everyone oh not guys too loud I don't
like hearing it no
that's too loud get more speakers I
guess
um everything is cranked up to 10 here
whoa look at that oh it's Chris Wham off
hey Chris wham-off Chris thank you for
everyone who contributors or streamlabs
too because uh they take less of a fee
than YouTube YouTube takes like 40 45 so
thank you guys so much audio seems fine
yeah you know what I want you guys to
fight about it spam the comments yeah
audio one to ten what do you think what
do you how would you rate the audio
experience of this podcast
do you realize
four six nine two zero nine zero zero
zero two one six three six two p13
pair one three yeah
I'm just afraid to like yellow piss you
guys all for the streams I'm not going
to here here now you can do it
um I'm just scared I don't want to wake
up the wife too uh I just got a chance
to watch it last night absolutely loved
it they moved forward the Gog T4 who
would you want to helm post gun oh what
a great question that is a very very
good question is who has the sensibility
you know who what I would want is uh
oh my God I think they would do great
like I hear they're doing the new Street
Fighter movie whoa and I think that is
perfect cool perfect choices especially
when you look at the YouTube videos
they've done
um I actually feel like yeah they might
not be such a bad pick for the Guardians
of the Galaxy 4 or
um who's good at like a team of Misfit
who's done a good like Misfits ones
who's gonna Misfits one David Ayer David
Ayer yeah Guardians of the Galaxy David
Aires it's set in East L.A and uh they
just have to go sort out gang conflicts
no we got more Super chess I just want
to make sure we caught up on the stream
Labs too I think you're right though I
think it has to be somebody like that
because I think the thing is like it's
not everybody has seen what James Gunn
did with troma but I think that is a key
part of his creative voice and growth
over time so I think you need somebody
who comes from a bit of a Gonzo but also
sort of a scrappy weird low budget
background just to translate this Same
Spirit I I don't know man I think I
really feel like they should end
Guardians uh one of the best things
about Guardians of the guy Galaxy to me
is the fact of how it really feels like
this is a director's movie you know with
with a little bit of MCU with a little
bit of uh Studio edit notes you know but
especially this one they even let him
say the word [__]
um it's just like surprising they even
had the whole face revealed thing with
high Evolution or I'm like that's very
violated they were allowed to do that
that's not even like quirky B-movie
violent the way how some of Multiverse
Madness is where you're like it's so
pulpy like a Multiverse of madness has
Gore but it's it's kind of pulpy Gore
right yeah what where this I'm like
that's genuine that's like a disturbing
image
practical effect like that's disturbing
with High evolutionary's face you know
and I wonder but beyond that like I'm
just saying like the whole sensibility
and editing and everything everything
about it feels like this is James Gunn's
voice where like you can kind of see it
with Thor 11th from Thor Ragnarok Thor
love and thunder like this The Look of
Love and thunder does not look like how
I imagine Taiko want
so I I really think that this particular
movie like this particular franchise I
don't feel like it would go back to
feeling like this is a director's Vision
I think it would go back to feeling like
they hired an independent director so
they could order around you know yeah I
I would be very curious because I I have
to I don't know James Gunn has a special
kind of it where I think his Visions
work well probably with what the
committee wants but also uh he seems
like he is formidable enough to secure
his own vision and I don't know who else
could really do that yeah and and we'll
get to another Super Chat somebody uh
pitched one but even then we'll talk
about it later
someone no no one Logan B and Sarah
Williamson you guys be nice to each
other oh guys everyone hug just I'll hug
it out
this is where I was worried about what
the pen is saying I saw little kids in
the theater
yeah I wonder if they used The Dark
Knight to argue for that to to get the
rating because like Two-Face is pretty
Grim but this is like it feels like
you're watching some kind of medical
video plus some sci-fi makeup around it
no Chanel thank you so much no Chanel
unrelated Gardens the Galaxy but I can't
get your merch because I live in the
Middle East oh you do oh do you think
you'd ever expand and include more
countries that would be nice to figure
out action I appreciate the the
streamlabs here but
uh I we do talk about it it's just a
it's it's still new even though the
people love I'm not just saying it
because I I want to raise I wanted to
work with Zero edition is because I
really love the the feel and the Des
obviously the designs but more
importantly I'm very particular about
the kind of fabric I wear on my body
like I'm very particular so I have a lot
of shirts I never wear
um but I was like okay I'll force myself
to to wear for like this one time for
this particular video but a lot of times
I just don't but the so I would love to
I'd have to talk with it just depends on
how the the growth of the company's
overall going but yeah of course we'd
love to expand more but thank you no
Chanel for supporting us anyway flev
Doran
flev Lev I really like the movie good to
hear good to hear because I know it can
be up and down for you
the mission to save rocket was part
really good but it's the ending that
left me tearing up but I don't know what
to feel about this recent trend of
open-ended finales like in Thor four
Thor will return but no one told Chris
that
well Thor I think will I mean even if
this takes 10 years in a recast Thor
will return because he's like a pillar
Avenger we want to get you that Joel
shirt no Chanel we want to oh absolutely
we sold over close to 200 shirts on that
oh hey
um sorry no Chanel but at one one of
these days dude you know what
I'll I'll uh Instagram message me uh
real Rejects
oh well yeah Instagram rejects it's
gonna message real Rejects and
um you know and and I'll see what I can
do
um
is the guy from Easter egg guy Coy Sarah
Williamson is that who you're talking
about there's the Easter egg guy or is
that Andrew uh
I mean I kind of feel like this has been
an MCU thing for a while though since
kind of the beginning am I wrong about
that no yeah they've been doing this
forever yeah I mean like I guess you
want them to tell people sure sure I I
don't like I think with Thor it makes
more sense because I think Thor is a
character whose mantle you could pass on
and not to say that like if the MCU is
just the thing that continues existing
eventually everyone's gonna have to get
recast eventually things will get
rebooted eventually you'll get your new
yeah whatever the Marvel equivalent of
like a new 52 situation is uh yeah like
I I don't know I don't
I don't know if I would want to see
Star-Lord anywhere near as soon as I
would be open to somebody else doing
Thor yeah
um
I just these characters seem so
specifically tied to James Gunn's style
and writing and voice and vision that
I'm just like
I kind of don't want to see any of the
other man feel like you can get away
with Groot I kind of don't want to see
any of them without
um without James Gunn being a part of it
I I really don't
it's like Thor's different because Thor
was like not conce this version of Thor
was not conceived by taika until
Ragnarok you know what I mean yeah so it
was we had Thor for a while before you
know taika stepped in
so yeah all right I gotta catch up here
thank you guys so much you guys are the
best you fueled these streams and we are
grateful for every one of you
except you you know you are I thought
okay I just kind of previewed a uh a
super chat about it but I I think it was
about the group line oh yeah about yeah
I love you guys yeah yeah on the second
viewing I was like oh I think I know
what's happening in this moment
um but I'll wait to save the opinion
[Laughter]
um let's see here pandemic Jones
thank you pandemic or yet oh yeah let me
find you let me find you right there
right here is that him
is that pandemic Jones
oh I got I need to I need to adjust this
hold on let's move it over to the right
yeah
there you are pandemic
chunky read it mantis was my favorite
the way Palm emotes his mantis just
makes me feel every emotion whether it
was laughing or crying especially her
yell for Peter at the end made my tears
flow she was great and I agree with you
I think she was great she's such a
lovely and quirky character and she
sells The Quirk so beautifully she sells
the the the kiddish knit like mantis
does also feel like a child in many ways
as does Drax and I feel like the way
they bounce off each other too is is so
lovely and and so well realized the
abalesque scene uh I think is wildly
impressive because she is working off of
nothing and she's like crying in this
yeah yeah when she's like you know
putting her face up against it and all
that stuff like well I what I think's
really
really cool because James Gunn does
strike me as a genuine animal lover I'm
very much an animal lover I gave up meat
because of watching videos one like for
hours about animals like that's what I
think of a very big animal lover she see
our backyard possums squirrels food left
out for all of them so yeah we got like
extended pets outside
um the the
um
but the Obelisk because they they kill
one at the beginning of Guardians two
yeah and it's like such a scary presence
so I think it works especially when you
see the scene in this one
when the others like oh man one was hard
you mentioned three this is terrifying
yeah they're all gonna die and we don't
have our amplifier here from the music
but then to her but then to but they
didn't have mantis with them in that in
that fight in the second one yeah that's
true yeah we didn't even met her yet and
then for it to come back around of these
are also just animals they don't eat
people they eat batteries I think it's a
perfect conclusion I really do I think
it's a solid conclusion and I feel like
Star-Lord really one thing I think
people underestimate about Star-Lord in
this movie is you watch him in his
journey from volume one to to this one
well he has some boyish moments in here
he overall goes from being a boy to
being a man yeah and I think it's
awesome like he's always been like he
went from like boy to teenager to man
you're really watching like grow up in
these movies totally totally and I
mantis though was perfect absolutely and
I do appreciate that moment for her
because it is one of those things where
there's so much continuity and so many
things get brought back for other more
like lore based reasons whereas this was
like we're bringing back a familiar
creature to give you a certain immediate
sensation but then we're also going to
showcase the growth of oh hey this thing
we used to just wantonly kill if it got
in our way or whatever now we're
actually going to think a little bit
differently about and that affects the
whole team you know
a thousand percent
hey Greg and John I've been a long time
real rejects fan as well as a fan of
Marvel in DC I would be very happy if
you give a shout out for superhero fans
here dude superheroes fans here you're
the best because you are here and you
are keeping the love and joy so there's
a lot of Anguish that surrounds the
conversations of these movies sometimes
but I appreciate that y'all are out here
keeping it enthusiastic real for your
support here on the Chanel and uh yeah
I'm trying to find you on Instagram and
Twitter what's the best way I don't see
you what's the best way to oh I closed
the super chats
everyone haul ass
it's okay it's okay we're gonna get it
fixed I hit the wrong button and now
everything is wrong now it's not that
time to panic
I'm last I'm lost the Super Chat
[Music]
oh I would love to see a Buzz and Woody
live stream
that's right
over here hold on guys right in front of
you there yeah hold on we just lost all
the viewers I don't even know how many
people are watching honestly and I don't
want to know
I just want to focus on the quality of
the stream everyone is watching are you
knocking babe
or is that the cats
that's the perfect
really good comedic timing actually
whatever that was copper or whatever
that was that was definitely I love that
bit when they're in the uh in the orgo
course uh the big Atrium in the order
chord but she grabs that one guy and
just says Kitty or whatever and he
starts acting like a cat
um
violent rage I also appreciate the
Oregon Corp sentries look like Dr Satan
see I felt like a lot of sometimes when
there's jokes
in the movie I think I think sometimes
people feel like and I'm not saying this
is for every joke I do think there are
some humorous moments that yeah it's
humor but it's I don't think it's meant
to be I don't know how to describe it
because there's a certain kind of dark
humor to James Gunn style where I don't
feel like it's meant to be like
hilarious every time yeah you know like
even like what you're just talking about
with with that moment what's it called
the Orville core orgo orgo core or the G
right orgo Corp and then and it's the
orgo scope or whatever that the actual
satellite is called
um like when she's turning people like
the dancing and stuff like there is a
humor to it or like when the monkey
attacks the girl at the end yeah I mean
that's that's like that's a heroic
moment but it's definitely a dark joke
so I don't think every joke is meant to
be like hilarious or like we need to put
it in here to like release tension or
something like that I think it's just
part of the world of James Gunn and it's
part of how this family speaks to each
other yeah
and I mean that that one bit with the
monkey I was like I think this is also a
comment on like yes we saved these this
is the thing that will likely happen
because it's an animal it does you know
like in monkeys can mess you up but also
we still gotta save them yeah you know a
thousand percent and I thought that was
a great way of of acknowledging some of
the difficulty of coexistence while also
you know prioritizing life yeah all that
bidness
but let's see here
all right here we go
oh yeah maybe the humor is definitely
not as prevalent at this time
um but it was I was still there I was
Charmed I was Charmed like I'll like you
know they're they're a bickering family
and I feel like it always added to the
Dynamics and then you know when it was
funny even better you know hi guys thank
you Mark Leach for being here Mark
Marcus leech mark
hi guys I loved how the characters have
each grown throughout the trilogy and
the scene where nebula gets emotional
when she hears Rock that's what I told
if you guys saw my Instagram post and I
met Karen Gillen that's what I told her
when she hears rocket after he wakes up
up and Cosmo is a good dog
um yeah I didn't I didn't I was weirdly
not tearing up
and um even though I was like finding it
really emotional and dark and all that
[__] uh it wasn't really teary up and
but the part that got me to tear up was
when nebula does here because it's just
coming off the heels of her being
enraged and getting into this fight with
mantis and being told for just being
like harsh and critical of people all
the time and and they're they feel like
they're about to die they're just
trapped here and after all this this
crazy harrowing Adventure they've been
on and then when she hears drax's like
she's just so she's so tough and then
she breaks down when she hears
um Rocket's voice being alive uh of him
being alive that moment
um I think is a fantastic nebula moment
an encapsulation of a big part of her
Arc as well sure that's the way she
played that I don't know is that little
hand over mouth just like overcome but
not yeah it's like the way she finds the
pitch to to how that would come out of
that character I think is really lovely
see it's interesting because I I don't
really I didn't really like nebula in
the first movie
um but at both times every time I've
seen Guardians one I've never been a big
fan of the portrayal of nebula
um but I don't but from Guardians 2 and
on I'm like he's great
like she just got like really great oh
yeah yeah and I love how much how much
of a character she is in this movie and
that she does become like you know the
de facto leader of nowhere or like I
thought that was a great sort of end for
her Arc in this I do like how there is
an F-bomb in this movie do you like how
there's an F-bomb in this movie but they
still have television censorship of
screw used in this film I know so many
times I'm like Gamora would walk off and
be like [__] you and [__] you it's like
I'm done you know yeah it is it does
call attention
but uh I'll take it I'll still take it
it's a harsh f word oh we're gonna get
demonetized oh
sorry that's harsh I'll say them they're
taken weirdly into context of how to say
the f word isn't that weird we didn't
say them sexually in any way
you said like we'll see we'll see I'll
go back that's why you guys Super Chat
streamlab to save us from such a
disaster
favorite line in the relating correct
thank you so much you and koi man
yeah research the rules of how this
stuff goes down
if you want to partake here on the
channel John sure of course otherwise
it's just going to be videos of only you
and Roxy and you and Taylor just in case
you and Coy people hate those videos
dude nobody wants to nobody wants to see
you and Roxy and you and koi nobody
wants terrible everyone hates those yeah
they do I haven't been coordinating with
terribility and going over a massive
list of movies she hasn't seen I haven't
been working my ass off to get her back
here Clayton crook
favorite line in the movie it's a
toss-up between she's a good dog and
there are hands and need us and the
hands that guide us made us
and made us that's not what it says
here's the guide is uh I'm reading it I
must be I'm being respectful to the
audience sure
you're being disrespectful to clean and
crook I am of course which is the name
of what villain and what Disney movie
Clayton crook it's just the first name
Clayton is the Disney villain in Tarzan
Tarzan that's right
that's good because I kept wanting ever
the whole time I kept wanting to call
him something else and and so yeah
anyway uh favorite line in the movie
what is your own favorite line in the
movie
favorite line of the movie that's a
great question favorite line in the
movie The Answer the hands that made us
in the hands that guide the hands is is
a pretty is a bar but I feel like that's
lifted from philosophy somewhere
um there are so many great lines yeah I
would need to I would need to
I would need to think
[Music]
I think I mean one of the least talked
about lines
it's not my favorite line but I think
one of the least talked about lines is
Nathan Fillion's lines
that is a hilarious joke yeah that was a
good reoccurring yeah
it just always feels he has to point out
like
this weight on his shoulders that he has
to drag around with him I thought it was
so [__] funny yeah yeah but dealing
with the nepotism that he has to bring
around your result I thought I thought
those jokes were so funny I thought you
said something else and it feel and I
like to because I wondered if it was
just um
if it was just like an improvised line
in the moment but based off the way the
camera angles were done and like when he
looks back over at that guy I'm like
okay now this is the plan part of the
script yeah that is such a funny ass
line
we're gonna get to I love you guys in
just a second oh yeah Ian Bloch thank
you so much
Thor predicted rocket being the captain
at the end of the third one in favor
ah my man that's right I didn't even
think about that oh not bad oh let me
ask the captain Oh wait a second it's me
that's right damn not bad I mean he was
the captain of the [__] that they took
off on was it when did that line come up
was it in was that was that I can't
remember if that line was when they had
already left
with when it was just Thor Gruden rocket
or was it um
was it before that I'm not sure either
way yeah
that is a powerful
that that moment is so beautiful when
they all
salute what is this yeah that's their
salute yeah the O Captain my Captain
moment yeah beautiful absolutely
beautiful moment yeah beautiful moment
I think the flashbacks are great Disney
fan and they were hilarious all funny
flashbacks just to add more to the
Marvel comedy of course the hilarious
tale of rocket and his friends
friends we're friends friends are great
to have friends as good friends good to
have friends and friends we're all gonna
live ain't nothing bad gonna happen
today dude
going Mach 5 podcast cool name hey guys
we all know koi is in your trunk you
can't keep that man in a trunk he'd be
talking to the trunk the trunk would
open itself
he would vibrate the seat to folding
down and then he would get out the back
door or the front door if the child logs
around but safe to say koi is not going
to be in that trunk for very long
and he'll he'll figure it out or or I
mean you know he'll find a way to like
do a full ass workout in there read 10
comics and then when you open the trunk
he'll just burst out and run away
um anyway was that our first F-bomb in a
Marvel property
and everyone's treating it as such so I
have to no it is the interviews have
said it and um and and I think it's
because there's been we've been on the
verge oh yeah I mean if you guys don't
cut away from it's amazing I don't know
if High evolutionary have King Tech I
don't doubt it doubt it I feel like he
would have his own deck
um so what James Gunn was saying was
that
um when when that F-bomb was presented
in the screenings and even though the
joke went over well he talked to Kevin
feige about it and Kevin feige brought
up how the Russo Brothers originally you
know that line I am Iron Man at the end
of end game
um the original line was something was
something along the lines of go [__]
yourself to hide it all right
that was one of the
that was one of the original that's that
was the original line before they had
Robert Downey Jr come back and change it
because Russo Brothers said they didn't
want that to be their legacy as the like
because if that is the final moment the
final line for Iron Man that would be
the most talked about thing yeah
we're supposed like a line and then and
then Kevin feige was like do you want
are you sure you want this to be your
legacy and then James goes like do you
not know who you're talking to of course
I wanted to be my legacy so he won so
yeah of course he would like of course
James Gunn would yeah and it's in the
kind of scene where it's notable but it
doesn't over like if it's not at the
climactic moment of this gigantic
multi-movie battle you know and I
thought it was also a fun way to liven
up you know a pretty classic joke about
the door handle
um
let's see here Dan v900 thank you Dan V
oh yeah you're actually were born to be
a dad I thought she was gonna say you
weren't born to be a destroyer you're
born to be a Healer Oh I thought that's
what she was gonna say and they said
damn like that makes more sense both
times I watched it I've totally forgot
the second time I thought I forgot the
line was dead I was like healer I don't
mess my mind keep going there
um gun confirmed uh that I love you guys
was for the audience understanding what
group was said where he didn't suddenly
learn other words it was well done yeah
that's great yeah the second time I
watched it it really dawned on me there
because the first time
the whole audience made so much noise
and I was I too was like you know like
oh Vin Diesel like I hear Vin Diesel's
voice I don't hear a Groot anymore yeah
actually this was the version of Groot
where I heard Vin Diesel's voice the
most did you this was a time where I I
could really hear Vin Diesel yeah um
whereas before I I couldn't really I
could imagine him in the booth and um
and he says I love you guys which uh and
the second time watching it because
they're not like reacting yeah it really
hit me in that moment that ah yeah
better that is just for us to hear it
yeah and I like that that it comes on
the heels at the moment where Gamora
learns to understand what he's saying
that was great yeah it's kind of like
it's kind of just like an intuitive way
of learning like you just learned with
feeling with group because you know um
Guardians uh
the post-credits scene of Guardian one
of one of the many post credit scenes of
Guardians 2.
when when when when Star-Lord is talking
with teen group
I'm like oh he's learned how to speak
group okay yeah so and I was like how
did that come about
um but then but then in Infinity War
Thor says that he
part of his um I I didn't go to college
what's it called extracurricular
programs or whatever
sure what's it called when you just like
take extra classes in school yeah like
an elective yeah yeah yeah yeah at that
elective was learning to speak group
sure so so I thought it was like I think
I think you have to really learn a
language but then here it kind of makes
it seem like it's a feeling that's like
an intuitive thing it seems like I mean
it seems like both and I imagine a good
if you had an actual Groot class
certainly it would be it reminds me of
one of those I don't know a ton of my
languages but one of those languages
where you can have like the same
syllables but depending on how you use
the vowels or how you intonate them they
mean differently Chinese is very much
like that where it's like you know you
can have the same technical like array
of sounds but depending on your
intonation or your inflection it changes
the whole meaning I don't think you need
to go with a giant room for the a movie
like discarding in particular I mean I
think it's better be great great to be
on a big screen but I don't think you
need to be with a packed audience doing
for this for this particular Marvel
movie I think it works both ways
um
let's see here the LA crooked oh yeah
there's a third afterlife huh I know I
think it was a real afterlife that he
went to I I think it was a real
afterlife that he went to before we get
to everything yeah I'm choosing that you
could you could go both ways for
different reasons the last crooked the
last scene with Krillin Gamora was
really beautiful
scene if I had some piece too with his
grandpa and her with a new family and
the ravagers yeah I thought that was
great I'm glad they didn't end up
together I thought I thought it worked
better especially for the character arcs
of both of them but especially Star-Lord
who is trying to get to a point of
acceptance and
and um
what was it about that oh I had another
thought they're trying to take it away
well I mean to the whole thing uh with
them I have this so when they blow up
the ship on Adam Warlock I was like oh
God please don't kiss like because I
think too you know like Peter starts out
as a rascal and as a guy who who like
the lily pad speech implies you know you
hop from woman to woman and yeah this is
about watching him like learn to just
respect who she is and I love that thing
she tells him about like why what are
you so afraid of that you need me to be
something and like that's a that's a you
know relevant topic not to go political
on you but like that's a great example
of like no this is this guy's real
growth and I think a lesser movie would
have been like no for things to be right
in the end they'll be back in love and
uh and I'm glad they chose the real life
more the more real life version of that
and that whole thing of I bet we were
fun is like such a heart wrencher you
know because uh because yeah like we've
all had that in some way shape or form
there's still a journey with them and it
and it still kind of leaves the door
open for a possibility for them because
and she starts off like very much
opposed to this guy yeah Quinn
um
and and then to go from that too about
to realizing like seeing through through
the course of the movie who he who he
really is
like I actually thought it made their
Dynamics more interesting you know not
not to go from him being like
heartbroken too
for him being like heartbroken to then
being
um you know getting mad at her for how
she's handling the the getting the file
but then when he's like snapping at her
during the the part when Rockets dying
and he's like I love I love uh Chris
Pratt's acting in that scene too yeah
when Star Lord's dying very believable
he's like snapping at
um you know even go more like no I'm not
gonna let it happen yeah yeah I'm not
I'm not letting him go yeah
um that's amazing uh let's see here tins
have you guys seen James Gunn's most
thank you for the super chat buddy have
you seen James got the most recent
interview where he said he made up the
backstory and finish stones in like 30
minutes and Marvel rolled with it I have
heard this I don't recall the exact
interview that I've seen
but that is hilarious because I know
they originally wanted him to be the one
who was like mainly in charge of the um
of the uh Cosmic side okay of the MCU
now he's taking all those ideas to the
DC Universe right
blue
it's gonna be it's weird it's great it's
better for us
some might not agree with that it's
it's better for us and like to my
opinion that like oh man James's gonna
run DC like the suicide squad's
incredible and I love most of his work
but
um
Man Marvel really doesn't shot
themselves in the foot of that day they
fired
yeah a while like yeah I'm very curious
to I mean you know like they've
moved without James Gunn in various ways
but I am very curious what the truly
post gun Marvel will be yeah but uh I'm
glad he's out there doing his DC thing
was I the only one uh jacqueria 69 was I
the only one hoping that uh High
evolutionary would evolve himself in one
of those tanks or be deleted by it in
the end from rocket
um yeah uh no I didn't quite go there I
did think it was a bit bizarre that they
don't just kill High evolutionary
I do I've yeah I've been chewing on that
a lot it's a very it's a very very very
I have that issue with a lot of movies
actually where they mow through a lot of
people to get to this guy to the person
to be like no you know what I'm bigger
than that yeah
and and I mean you've seen I mean it is
a debate that that rages in any War
scenario but yeah it's like this person
clearly responsible for so much chaos
torture and destruction
you know should we High Road this guy or
not and I mean part of me bought in this
context I mean I'm sure you can always
magic the high evolutionary back but
part of me was like I feel like he's
going down with the ship I feel like
this is the end and so I'm not that
upset by it however it could easily not
be yeah so so yeah I appreciate the idea
and I appreciate maybe in that moment
it's all sort of starting to hit but I
also get that it's not the most perfect
moment in the movie
um yeah man
um
High evolutionary though
he had some great scenes I don't think
he was too easily defeated
it took them all no it took all of yeah
it took all of them and I mean it it
took a lot to get to I think the movie
could have utilized a little bit of
having to use some strategy to really
fight to get to him or something or take
it I don't know his kind of does that
kind of any like space battle stuff and
I do think it could have utilized it's
one of my favorite Parts about
I don't think it's necessarily fair to
compare evolutionary to Thanos but it is
one of my favorite Parts about Infinity
Wars like just how much like constant
re-strategizing they have to do to take
this guy down yeah yeah and I do think
that would have been yeah the yelling
gets a bit the part of the yelling
that's being brought up in the channel
I'll address it right now the part I
noticed it on my second View and like
when does the yelling become too much uh
the yelling becomes too much it's it's
right after rocket comes back
and um you know actually from the whole
Heaven scene and then High evolutionary
interrupts the call and he's like and
then he's showing that like I got mantis
uh Drax and nebula then his role becomes
I am mainly just a yelling guy yeah and
then it becomes a no that's that's when
it starts to become a bit annoying yeah
because it's it's suddenly just losing a
bunch of different nuance and it's it's
not even like different shades of
yelling it's like this dude is screaming
vehemently at the top of his lungs every
single time and that's the part and
because I'm like before that there are
some more nuanced later scenes like one
of the things that you brought up was
that scene when
um he's coming and behaving like a drunk
dad you said yeah uh in one of the
flashbacks when he's trying to present
to Rocket like how did you figure this
out yeah yeah yeah and he after the that
whole line about like his treatments and
and yeah then he like tries to compose
himself like oh hey sorry hey I want to
talk to you about this but then the but
then the but then after that he he
becomes it becomes like a one note type
of where the yelling loses its impact
whereas before it could strike fear yeah
and now the yelling is just okay you're
just kind of loud
and you're losing a lot so to me while I
feel like
do you not pronounce his name Chuck
Woody oruji there you go well I feel
like he still does a great job and like
even in that like it is the I don't
think it's like I feel like he was doing
what was asked of him to do and I'm
seeing in the chat there's a lot of
people who aren't bothered by it
um I was one of the people that was like
this is becoming a little much for me
but that you know strike me as you were
bothered by it no but I get it like I
can see it and I wouldn't turn down like
an extra layer of pathos or Nuance to
those late moments but it it made sense
to me yeah I see doe as I was telling
that to John just yesterday like I feel
like I see the intent yeah of it
becoming like yeah it's supposed to be
more desperate and more unhinged at this
point like I get it
um but
at the same time yeah I just still like
yeah I could use a little bit more
layers
Moro is correct though it should have
been We Are Family the Groot said at the
end
uh I wonder if it was husker4life 109
the yelling was good it was good yelling
all the proper vocal warm-ups it's not
even like a relationship fight yelling
where you're like I'm not yelling this
is yelling yeah that was real yelling
sure that must have been a loud set to
be on
it doesn't matter how do you record all
that audio with one guy at 10 and
everybody else at like three I feel like
you could be more menacing in like like
that is one of the parts about Thanos
that like I I don't think it's fair to
compare this guy to Thanos I really
don't because I'm like that's a
completely different kind of build up
and a completely different type of
villain
um that there is the there is one of my
favorite Parts about Thanos in the end
because like in the comics for Thanos
he's the Titan yeah he's essentially
what high evolutionary is doing the
whole time I'm just oh we're screaming
and I got like the comic books panels
that the captions are all like just big
text and just like a little expressive
rage
um but then in the movies he's he's a
lot quieter he's more contained and then
here I liked when it was more of a
mixture yeah well because with Thanos
yeah you can you can see him thinking
and strategizing and and he is I don't
know he is an interesting character I I
liked watching him overall more than
Kang I did too
um and and at least from compared to the
movies
um Husker for life 109.
thank you looks like Adam drivers
confirmed to play Reed Richards yep
talked about it a lot last live stream
it's pretty obvious he's going to be
I thank you for the Super Chat
I'm very excited for Adam Driver I wish
they would Reserve this casting
announcement for after the weekend of
Guardians of the Galaxy like
come on Marvel yeah what do you need a
boost or something I mean is it I don't
even know if it's like an official
announcement like I haven't we we've
been live streaming yeah so send us a
link
link us to it
um
you see that it is one of the weird
Parts about okay I create two cop here
all right Frank DX thank you so much
this movie is the example why we love
the MCU saw it last night we have tears
sad and joyful moments what do you think
they'll do with Adam Warlock
um okay it's just the leakers all right
uh well thank you for the Super Chat
Frank DX with Adam Warlock it makes
sense to have him here especially with
the more Cosmic side I feel like he can
have a standalone movie I don't really
know what that direction will be but you
know as a fan of The Infinity Gauntlet
comic book uh which you know the
infinity War Saga is heavily inspired by
can you let him in John all right I'm
closer to the door Alone
um
which was what was really inspiring is
cats going bananas get in here come here
come here
Jesus come here Copper Top freaks freaks
freaks mine freak I I really think what
would be great to utilize him in for the
special powers that we are not aware
that he is capable of will be used for
can be used for
um uh the secret Wars especially
especially Secret Wars so yeah like we
didn't get to use him for Infinity War
which a lot of people were bummed by
some people really felt like oh I wish
because he was such an integral part of
the especially the comic is focused on
yeah but that is um but I think that's
when we'll really see more
Adam Warlock I think they're gonna he's
gonna have a lot of off-screen character
growth
yeah I would love a device that allows
him to grow on screen because I did find
the the character stuff they gave him in
this movie quite fun and charming and I
thought he did a really terrific job
with it I can most logically see him
showing up in a lot of group activities
but it would be nice to have something
where he is like prominently featured
even though even if he isn't the lead
yeah you know even if it's not Adam
Warlock the movie
I don't think any of them needed to die
man I'm okay with them not dieting yeah
it's not like quantumania where you're
like this could have gotten you know
more impactful if maybe there was some
loss or something like there's there's
so much other stuff that happens that I
don't think the deaths are are required
yeah I see I feel like with Adam Warlock
I feel like with Adam Warlock he's
perfect for
is that perfect I don't feel like any
part of it is perfect with Adam Warlock
I think he works great for a James Gunn
movie sure
as far as an MCU and a Marvel Comics
interpretation of him like I could see
something like I don't know about this
but he works well within with a James
Gunn movie is and it's not surprising
when it's James Gunn and you still get
to see the potential of what he can
evolve into from what you might love
about Adam Warlock to begin with yeah he
works well in the hands of a of a
director who can
Embrace what is kind of absurd about the
character but also you know give him
some life and uh I feel like he could
easily fall into being
I don't know I I feel like the levels of
that character could easily becoming
congruous in the wrong hands yeah
nerdy film girl thank you so much lamb
shank lamb sharp no I wasn't screaming
at you I was screaming at something
behind you you look super cool
thank you that's such a sad like that's
what I mean it's a dark James guns this
was Guardians 2 I thought he displayed
some of his dark humor but I don't think
it went over that well especially on the
first go around yeah and and then I
think on this one he really showed more
I mean The Suicide Squad is like full of
Darker
um well to me it's the second one seemed
like it had the humor of dysfunction
whereas this one seemed like it had the
humor of dark circumstance yeah because
you can have like the these dire moments
and these truly tragic things with the
animals but then you have like this
humor with the lamb lamb shank moment
that you know what I mean and that
moment for some people it's not gonna be
funny at all you know I'm like well you
see it and yeah the whole point is like
oh it's got like Bones on the outside
like yeah it is but it's but it is
played for like a kind of like dark
comedy and they treat him with dignity
just the same uh like yeah yeah it's
strange and off-putting in a way but
also endearing and lovely and I mean
like this movie has like so much of that
James Gunn trauma Enis yeah just like
gross tactile Gonzo quality
farc cash 1987 wish gun would show
refrain on cramming pop music and
when it's so frequent it takes away the
impact it should have in my opinion
warlock was wasted too I know he should
have sobered up
because the music wasn't constantly
coming from
Star-Lord Zoom is it a zoom zoom iPod
June is it a Zune or is an iPod no it's
a zunia uh yeah they make a whole deal
about that uh if it wasn't coming from
there I I I I think uh I mean there's a
couple of times no no it's usually
coming for they usually sometimes
sometimes they introduce it with the
song like playing and then you then they
reveal it's coming from the zoo or
something like like with Adam warlock's
introduction which I love because when
he's first flying his face is it feels
like a Flash Gordon you kind of yeah
it kind of sets the vibe for him in a
way to like uh be like it's cool but
it's also kind of funny it's nothing
funny about this yeah yeah and and I
think with uh this thank you Nicholas um
so yeah that's why it never bothers me
and so because it still feels within
tune of of the characters uh I know he
does it in like all of his movies still
like he's The Suicide Squad it's just
music uh but I I feel like like Edgar
Wright he chooses the songs before
because I I even heard that even for a
lot of the times on the sets he will
have the music playing yeah and he'll
help the actors give it get a sense of
what this seemed like what to feel like
and stuff and it's an actors actually
like that because especially if there's
gonna be like a slow motion moment did
James Gumball inform them of that so it
could change their movement around to
fit for it better and
um so yeah I I feel like it's always
very much purposeful it doesn't feel
like Studios trying to cram something in
that the youth will like older people
will feel Nostalgia for you know no I
love in fact this was uh probably my
favorite of his I mean he always puts
together fun and interesting soundtracks
and I like most all of them to one
degree or another but I love the way
this movie made it uh just I don't know
it had this human detail of like we all
listen to music and not everyone's like
a music obsessed person not everyone's
like a music of us whatever you call
that file
um but you know it's like in various
moments like rocket in is like kind of
singing along and everybody is listening
to the music together and so like they
really made our connection with music
something tactile in this movie to where
like that's how I would be like if I was
up on the ship with um you know my
little team like I would be I would have
the iPod on me all the time you know I
would always have the me like if we're
in transit to another thing that we're
you know about to fight or rescue or
whatever I would absolutely have like my
psychup playlist and whatnot so uh I
like yeah that they motivated it in this
movie and that you get that growth if
he's even added some 2000s music yeah
you know
dark days
well like again that's like a
well-chosen cathartic song like a great
choice
I even uh you know even on the second go
around it's a detail I noticed was how
Drax
at the beginning says dancing is for
idiots yeah and then at the very end he
dances with the kids yeah and he calls
their kids idiots and stuff too yeah
that's great well and even his dance is
like yeah absolutely and like that whole
big thing gets made in the second one
about like I love my wife so much for
it's just how much she didn't dance so
yeah seeing him then give in in a way
that still feels appropriate it's like
you know he's he's throwing caution to
the winds and having fun being silly you
know which with the kids is perfect yeah
yeah
yeah Fighters talk if we talked about it
um Serena Cuevas
uh thank you Serena like I love your
name
I love that even though this was this
mainly was rocket story every single
character had their moment in growth
individually and as a team love y'all
that's one of the things about the
structuring I really appreciate about
this film I saw a couple of people even
say it in the chat
um imagine it's been one or two I don't
know but uh wow strangers crying you in
the theaters that's [__] up that's
messed up I mean how obnoxious are you
being
I yeah were you was elect this person
I'll never forget from from Avengers end
game and Spider-Man no way too someone
there's oh Spiderman and he was so
obnoxious that person had their person
they were with had to tell them to come
to like to be quiet yeah they were
inconsolable and also quite uh you know
yeah visible in their anguish yeah and
we were all like we love Spider-Man too
but but come on let's remember what
movie we're at you gotta understand it
is like um it is like uh you know
I I don't know it is like uh
what's like a really just terrible death
for someone crying have you guys seen
The Godfather Three
like Al Pacino's crying now it's like
what it was like it's not that
this movie's not about you yeah yeah
we're all here I would never judge
someone for crying ever um especially in
a theater
um but yeah but it was it was enough
that everyone was kind of yeah just
everyone's attention sort of went there
um but yeah I think one of the best
parts about the structuring
um thank you for your consideration uh
for best parts of the structuring is to
me is that yeah Rocket's not with the
team a lot of the time so it's cool that
he was James Gunn was able to formulate
his story where everyone gets a chance
to shine
but you could also make it still Rockets
movie by serving his story within the
flashbacks and I thought that was great
because then you bring the two tails of
full circle like I love when rocket
wakes up and Rocket has no idea of the
the undertaking they just went on for
you get this guy to be alive yeah that
whole thing like where's nebula yeah her
calm codes up on the screen yeah yeah
yeah that uh that was that was I think
the structuring of it is great because
yeah it's a weird thing where it can
have this effect where you're like ah
there's kind of a bit of a missing
presence of Rocket not being around
interacting with the team but that's
kind of the point yeah because they're
trying to save this guy
yeah he's a presence even when he's not
interacting with them and and yeah like
I think I would love you know like a
deep dive on some of these James Gunn
scripts from his perspective just
because he is good at holding on to the
different traits of the characters and
really fleshing out their Dynamics
individual visually or with one member
versus all the members and yeah
everybody's I feel like core character
Theme you know is touched upon and grown
in this movie somehow and that's what
makes the action so rewarding in that
hallway fight especially when Rockets
like going in there messing [__] oh I
love it man yeah I'm done running it's
one of the few times and like that's
it's funny like you know in a lot of
ways Guardians is very much like suicide
squad and The Suicide Squad
um but yeah like that was a moment too
where he's in the hall and he gives you
know it's one of those things that
happens often where they'll throw in
like a woohoo or something along those
lines and usually that takes me out I'm
like okay that's for the kids but in
this situation it was like oh I'm glad
to see rocket back on the job and
enjoying himself for a second despite
all the circumstances you know get in a
rush there with you Johnny
good [__] I guess that's bigger what am
I doing I don't
first you reference Godfather 3
announcements
oh yeah that's right Linda carterley I
was surprised but but uh yeah like once
once you hear it it's definitely her and
I thought she did such a lovely job for
a character who you know you you don't
see the actor behind
all three of them
thiefs and uh and floor as well
the panda
chat from you thank you for your
contribution after Reacher could we see
oh this is this is a good time to
readdress this uh we could can we see
soups and lowest reactions this season
has been the best so far it's been
phenomenal and I've also been a fan
since you were Ryan Wright but never
like the Jerry no Jerry screw that guy
um no I wanted to give you guys the
blunt version uh especially after having
uh one day where this week um I am not
proud of this didn't like talk about on
social media or anything like that uh
there was one day I had I worked
literally 18 and a half hours and it was
not spent filming reactions all day all
right I did like one
um the yeah afterward that was like well
I really did that I hate I really did
not like the feeling of that
um and Superman and Lois and and I but I
used the time to kind of do a
calculation on things of like how long
does an average how much do I averagely
get done with an edit within if it's
like a 45 minute show how long is it on
average take me to get through the first
15 minutes and then how long does an
average thumbnail take me to feel like I
was trying to like do the math on all
these things
um because I just kind of wanted to know
for the future and uh yeah bottom line
is Superman and Lois like as much as as
great as the show is
uh it is just way too low of a performer
for us on this channel and and uh and
sometimes it's like you know it might
not do great on this on the channel
because it's not just about it's like
at times like okay the amount of time if
I if I put on the work to put this video
together I'm not making even like
minimum wage on this video so if I'm
hiring someone to help put it together
we're not making a single profit on the
time
but I'm like you know I also got like
people like there are multiple people uh
and it's a part of the journey that I'm
learning I especially I'm learning right
now with hiring more people and I'm in
this weird spot where I'm like I thought
I remember people would mean I work less
but somehow it's led to me working more
and as I don't quite get like and I know
other people who often fall into that
boat when they start hiring more people
so it's a thing I'm learning of how to
I've had a handle but yeah I'd like to
especially with the way last month went
down like there would have been no
chance for Superman and Lois to possibly
live and it just wouldn't have Justified
the time to spend all the time it would
take to put one of those videos together
so yeah it just doesn't um just doesn't
it's not it's not the right time
we are totally dizzy Brown knows that's
why we severely recommended Amen in the
WASP quantumania oh yeah and go watch
their Pinocchio remake too that was
amazing we made sure here on this
channel that people knew how much we
loved that and if you see our Little
Mermaid trailer the reaction wow wow
could not have been more positive during
that yeah Disney chills Galore right man
um but I we've had a lot we've had more
people on the YouTube interested in it
but it just I didn't it just didn't
justify it and and even our patreon
barely anyone would watch it
um like literally we got a couple
thousand patrons and then we would
average 14 people watching the
watch-alongs or at least with like
Brooklyn nine nine you know like that's
a low performer on this channel very low
but we at least get a decent amount of
our patrons who watch it so you know
it's it somehow justifies it you know
and they're much shorter and at the end
of the day it's like I do have to
consider that uh that's just I I have to
consider you know it's something I'm not
the biggest fan of talking about
um I I do though um when it comes to
like you know what if it's not even
making minimum wage does it really makes
sense anymore to commit 16 weeks or so
yeah
Jordan Garza uh for salmon one day I
mean when salmon season two comes out we
might get around to doing Sandman
um season one because uh yeah at least
we can like bulk shoot that get it out
of the way
it's like visions
Jordan Garza don't worry I'm here boy so
happy to finally not miss a live thanks
Jordan Garza absolutely love the movie I
had so many tears teasers taser faces at
the end what an experience yeah man it's
amazing it's amazing movie I'm glad you
had a great time with it no alcohol
required is that what Jeremy John's
rated it did he I
I watch I listen to the room I almost
remember what his rating was I watch
almost every single Jeremy John's review
almost every single one we've met Jeremy
Johns a couple times extremely nice guy
loved it loved the few the little bit
time we got to spend with a little bit
of time being like a half hour right
it's been a good amount of time with the
guy uh one time John and I did an
interview for something and and he was
the only one who stuck around and
watching it and he's watching the whole
thing for like an hour giggling off
screen very nice guy and I love he's one
of my favorite people on YouTube hands
down and it was one of those things
where I listened to his review and I was
like wow I really could not disagree
more with this yeah and his fit and
everyone's attached their own opinion
nothing about what he said upset me I
was just it was one where I'm a little
bit surprised by this one uh a little
bit surprised especially when they say
it's like he said something along the
lines and maybe I'm getting this wrong
so I'm saying that to clarify say in my
ass case I am
um he did say a good time of your truck
that uh like at the end of the day it's
fun typical MCU formula and I was like
yeah I don't think so he said something
like it's like the rocket story then
wrapped in a typical MCU movie or
something like that and and yeah I don't
either I I feel like this is I I feel
like if this was your typical MCU movie
I would be stoked I've never said that
before stoked but I would be I mean this
was the caliber we could often expect
yeah I mean like Guardians 2 at the end
does have like a random I'm gonna turn
this into saving the universe thing uh
it right yeah yeah okay it does become
that but and here the people they're
saving and stuff I'm like that's been
laced through it since the very
beginning of this movie is these people
who animals people and the whole point
is equality and and and like the value
of their lives should not be diminished
just because they're not human yeah you
know and they're saving the people and
the creatures on this ship yeah so we're
so to me I'm like no that's been laced
throughout it that this was going to
happen so yeah
um yeah of course I I was one of the
people who thought about uh Sid from Toy
Story too yeah yeah especially yeah
especially came to the Buddy uh there's
always a hater who shows up in the
streams you know how they can be they
just want attention got to take your
opportunity to say it to our face yeah
I'm not all these years now one person
has come up to me and said something
rude to my face I just like when when is
it gonna happen then I'll be like
that's I respect you I would legit be
like at least you said it right to me
what's your username we'll make sure we
never blocked it yeah like you're
allowed man you want a [__] talk it's
fine because no one has ever said it to
my face I've had people comment be like
if you ever see that Greg in person he's
so cringe I'm gonna punch him in the
face like where's your fists
where's your Fizz I kind of go to the
same spots all the time
it's actually really easy to find
because I'm at the same locations all
the time
um Andrew thank you I want our dude
Olivia will mess you up though oh yeah
she'll fight my battles um favorite line
from Shanghai Knights
[Laughter]
um I wanted Star-Lord and nebula to
become a thing
that was a hilarious moment that's a
joke that normally I don't think would
go down like oh look at Marvel under
stupid comedy but that joke genuinely
worked
um and that was one of the few times you
see him back to his boyish ways I
thought that joke really worked well
yeah and I feel like that's another
relatable moment in a group of friends
that you know has guys and girls in it
or whatever and somebody makes the
suggestion and for a moment you're like
well maybe yeah you know and then you
know it doesn't persist but yeah I
thought it was good Greg you got a great
face
uh you do I haven't say that to my face
I haven't seen Barry yet um it's the
latest season um I'm I'm waiting to
watch that with my my wife uh we're
gonna be Olivia who I think popped up in
the chat I think I saw her name yeah she
just said she would uh the people should
say it to her faces with her there she
um yeah we just kind of want to binge it
the show was so we're so close to the
the end I'm so sad it's ending
Jordan Garza uh thank you Edgar
[__] ride is Guardians 4 I
don't think that guy is ever I don't
think to the MCU I don't think here Joe
Cornish are interested I think he's
totally gonna do something at DC that
would be so cool I like
you guys don't understand I don't think
you guys really get it
James Gunn is revered and respected
advice so many of his colleagues and
peers you know what I mean sure sure and
people and audiences generally admire
his work
what he's doing doing these when that DC
Floodgate opens up like and the kind of
filmmakers who are going to agree to do
the films there are going to be very
surprised I think I think they're going
to be we're gonna be like holy crap yeah
this is a true competition for Marvel
because of who they got here Scorsese
can you imagine
dude against
a movie about Carmine Falconi or
something like this I think Edgar Wright
will 100 do a DC movie I could see that
for sure they once did a trailer
reaction together
um Dan v900 thanks for being back here
uh the high evolutionary was an awesome
villain and more threatening than Kang
yeah because he actually has some [__]
to threaten with versus I'm just gonna
be a little bit spooky my monologues
well yeah you can see the direct result
of what he is doing I'm completely fine
with him coming even even his power of
high revolutionary that one of the
typical you know villain powers of the
moving [__] around it's all the kinetic
ability device even King has that
um but the only thing she doesn't have
his laser hands yeah and he could get
laser hands he's the whole thing is Body
Mods so like he could easily upgrade
himself if he were to come back I'm
completely fine with him coming back is
the ultimate King who wants to wipe out
everyone to create the perfect Society
honestly I mean I can see it if they
what if they needed an escape hatch yeah
then he could return they're like whoa
It's a high Evolution no I was Kang all
along I just called myself High
Evolution you know what it was about the
yelling who could bring it back to the
yellow like to bring it back to the
yelling of why I think the yelling
doesn't fully click I mean I know I'm
not the only one and a lot of people are
totally cool with it I thought it really
worked and I appreciate the intent
choice to show how much more unhinged
he's become
as as many of you have heard many actors
say many times that villain the best
kind of villains are the ones who do not
view themselves as the villain that they
view themselves as like like someone
like high evolutionary review themselves
as as righteous right uh right righteous
right that's right right as righteous
and that his choice is the correct way
to go about life and he's doing it for
good and I think that side of high
evolutionary was very much present
for a lot of that film but then in the
last like half like 20 minutes of the
movies 25 minutes is when that site gets
dropped he's just playing maniacal
villain yeah that's the part of word
yeah happens you know I gotta put this
shirt this is a real rejects exclusive
shirt what have I been doing this whole
thing Alba original design what am I
doing this whole stream guys I'm gonna
just let me just pull it up here I have
mine in the mail I'm gonna put this is
that where the sales came from that's
right he's like oh my God we sold so oh
and that midnight navy is such a you're
gonna get so mad at me I was like yeah
it's okay it's okay that it happens now
get this space baby shirt you know what
I loved too uh just just a random thing
I noticed uh is that they go to Batman's
house in this movie I mean bat woman
helps them but you know she lives with
the Batman and thus they go to Batman
and batwoman's house
put this away for a second
there's a real rejects exclusive shirt
people that boy look at that I don't
want to mess with the dimensions too
wait I could just do this for a brief
moment that controls you all right yeah
look at that there's babies at the
Galaxy
beautiful
we're just waiting just waiting to get
damn trouble pass copyright yep don't
don't ask questions John unless you ask
I'm even surprised
it's okay it's uh you know they're
they're just uh reminiscent of they're
not the actual uh
if you notice at least 20 percent has
been transformed
significantly from The Originals
I mean you know especially with Groot I
think there are many phases we have not
seen represented so you could easily get
away with it true I'm going to recheck
the stream Labs here for a second check
the lab John read the chat what's going
on there oh why the chat is my oh that
one can see the chat here that's right
uh
no one being killed we've talked about
this but I think it works quite well you
know I feel like they didn't need it
ultimately it once they wrapped
everything up it made sense and I think
it's better to send everybody off in
their own directions to start new
Journeys there's still a sense of loss
you take with that there's still a need
for acceptance and a bargaining with
things like that and uh and I think
moving on is a death of some kind and uh
and I think that's appropriate for what
this is and I think they faked us out on
enough deaths and showed us enough death
and despair that ultimately I think it
works the way okay where is John what's
his thing
bothering me uh uh whatever we'll make
it yeah we'll make it I'll find out
Liberty mommy's asking thank you Liberty
Mommy thanks for the stream guys Greg
workspace baby shirt it's amazing well
it's real Regis exclusive you can get a
shopzeroedition.com
Booyah I do I do love this shirt it's
super duper cute yeah and it's super
cute comfy space babies of the Galaxy I
gotta promote it yeah my promotion
skills are down it's okay you'll you'll
you'll have like a whole marketing Wing
set up by tomorrow absolutely worth
getting you'll love it you'll get
compliments I wore it to the theater
yesterday and people are like I love
your shirt and I said thanks go to shop
zero editions don't sell me [__] we're
in person and I'm like fine take my
shirt fine here's my shirt I'm gonna
walk out of here
and then uh and while you're at it
browse all the other lovely stuff
there's the there's the there's the
Child Protection Services T that's
pretty sure get the space babies just
get the space babies the stream no no
refresh and everything don't worry we
don't end we don't we don't miss a Super
Chat don't you worry it's revenge of the
sixth don't you worry
I mean and if you are worried we're
gonna assuage your worries soon enough
all right we're gonna rock you to sleep
in the cosmos
uh we're getting there X fire don't
worry if if we haven't read it yet it is
incoming and uh and yeah I feel like we
will see Rocket and Groot again somehow
maybe I don't know like I could they
could easily just leave it off there
like oh they just continued on to do
more Adventures uh but at the same time
uh yeah I feel like we could see them
again he's late no no one has ever
complimented by the way actually I I
somebody did recently and I and I was
thinking to myself that's I have never
received that compliment so this is that
might have even been you uh so thanks
I've never yeah I've never been forced
to be like are my legs okay I usually
feel like they're they're just average
and not extraordinary but I appreciate
the love
Greg has
fantastic legs all right
appreciate that yeah anything to make
about me again yeah no you and koi both
just make me feel ashamed of myself
every time I see it's the goal that's
why we work out I know and I'm like
weightlifting I can't I I'm so well
attuned to cardio and not to
weightlifting
you burn more weight and lose more
weight I know
[Laughter]
cardio is not helping me that's a
sculpture body uh I know Josh Ren
I'm I'm very happy with the emotional
Story the MCU has been lacking recently
it felt like Marvel okay I thought you
were saying I'm very happy with the lack
of emotional storytelling and I was like
this this sentence is confusing me
um Crockett's backstory made me cry so
much and I was shocked how violent it
got hallway fight for the win
I didn't find it that violent or that
dark the first time I watched it and I
think
see before before my epic re-watch of
everything I watched The Suicide Squad
first because Love is Blind failed to
air
after I napped out my entire week
really I was on set for something I'm
for I can't talk about I was on set for
something and I was there and the little
crew that was there I was like guys I
gotta make sure I'm back by five
so we're already going over but I gotta
make sure I'm back by five
after hours of trying
just decided to watch The Suicide Squad
again I was like God yeah I forgot how
much I love this movie great and then I
decided so then it's just like you know
let me put on Guardians next we kind of
cool to go back and then I just LED it
too like oh yeah I should probably just
rewatch this whole thing right just
because I got volume three coming up
um and uh and I think because maybe I
started off with guard with the suicide
squad that whatever happened and I do
feel like the the darkness that happens
in this movie which has often been
um part of the discourse with this film
of how dark it is I don't think it's
I still don't find it too dark I I
really don't I think it earned its way
there and I think it's a natural
trajectory like freaking
Thanos the father of Gamora murders
Gamora in a really like harsh scene
throws her off of a cliff and she's
struggling to get away off of learning
that this is his way of showing love oh
my God that is dark uh nebula be like
the constant torture and dismantling uh
the the Sinister abusive ways of ego and
the the pit of skeletons in in in
Guardians too like the movies got dark
already and this was the ultimate
conclusion of that Darkness coming to
light and and that's a big part I
thought it's like thematically worse I
don't feel like it's too dark and I know
a lot of people
take gripe with it do I think it's for
kids this movie no no I do not uh I do
not think it I'm like no I think you
gotta like warn your kids like there's
there's some real like dark [__] in here
it's not even like fun dark of like
amlet entertainment ways like this is
really dark so yeah I I I like it's it's
dark for especially for children but I
don't think some people what I'm saying
is some people were upset
by the darkness and
I not one part of me even registered on
my first viewing like oh I wonder how
the dark stuff is going to go over like
I didn't even think about that until I
saw the discourse when I'm like no it
earned its way there so yeah like
there's there are moments like high
evolution in his face I was like I am
surprised that Marvel let them do it for
a PG-13 movie a little bit surprised I'm
surprised the MPAA let them do that for
PG-13 movie because that's like pretty
that that is like an exceptional Gore
gag and that is like
I don't know looks again it's movie
Magic it probably doesn't look real but
it looks pretty real and you're like
doing a big close-up on the face yeah
you're letting that whole effect play
and he's trying to talk through it and
stuff and and yeah it's I mean certainly
I think by comparison it is one of the
most dark and horrific Marvel movies but
I also yeah like leaving it the first
time it's like I noticed that level of
Darkness but I wasn't
like I I yeah I was kind of surprised
that that some of the discourse I mean
I'm not shocked that it's you know
upsetting for people certainly and I do
think that that is a swing but I also
wasn't bothered I was like yeah this
seems like this is where this movie was
gonna go yeah so
uh Josh Reddin
we did your question yeah
it did take maximoff the PG-13 to the
Limit as somebody said like PG-13
doesn't mean anything anymore and people
say that a lot but this was one movie
where I was like look kind of kind of
pushing Ryu cat Ryu cat
guardians galaxy 3 Rider is a Chad
okay does that mean uh a Chad is like a
derogatory for like a bro-ish kind of
Meathead guy if I'm interpreting this
correctly
you know huh frat boy
this became The Last of Us for me
evolutionary wants to take Rocket's
brain to create a peaceful race like the
fireflies wanted Ellie like Joel
Guardians chose family
um
I mean you can spoil a lot of stories
down these core Parts wait a minute no
no no no
no no super what do you mean Super
chat's not sending that's a goddamn
crime if they're not uh call Jeff
YouTube
um
uh
uh wait a minute
um no uh that's different because
the the the massive difference is that
in the last of us
there might be a potential to save
Humanity yeah uh via Ellie it's
salvation yeah it's not here selfish
yeah yeah that's that's totally
different it's not maniacal adherence to
a singular Vision it's like we need we
could maybe yeah stop this thing that
killed all of us yeah we could cure this
and also yes that most certainly would
have been a Franz Ferdinand uh yeah to
your comment up there in the live chat
fire
uh x-fires sapphires fire
a guy Richie directed Misfits MCU film
uh he seems to be playing well with
Disney yeah I mean she's certainly doing
doing stuff what's the next one he's
doing
I know he did Aladdin and he's doing
another one isn't he yeah what is that
he's doing a whole lot of stuff all of a
sudden a Disney Guy Ritchie he's doing
The Little Mermaid too
he's Hercules Hercules that's what he's
doing next I'm surprised at this turn in
his career like I I mean there are a lot
of things you can do for money but I'm
also surprised that he's adapting these
animated Classics I mean he could work
in the MCU I mean to me that would be
akin to I feel like a guy Rich MCU joint
would feel like a Matt Vaughn MCU joint
there's just something about
that was that that's there's there's
just something about what you say like
kind of Richie MCU yeah I guess
guy Richie in the DCU and James well
yeah oh he can do his own thing yeah
yeah and it's like guy Richie has enough
profile and I'm like I bet his MCU movie
would look like a guy Richie movie but I
feel like a DC guy Richie movie would
behave like a guy yeah so I don't know
it could be cool but it wouldn't be yeah
it wouldn't get me as hyped not sushi
thank you I recognize this guy
hell yeah oh
is that a star war
that's a that's an errand
that's an aot oh sorry we're just
watching all those animated Visions
that's cool though one day I'll watch
Attack on titron
it's great it's great so I've heard
loved loved the manga too Joshua thank
you so much for that um by the way my
Attack on Titan reactions are all on
patreon because YouTube scares me with
anime I know too many people who do it
oh yeah that's that's pretty much me
there's a man Joshua Pepsi poly that's a
pretty good assessment to me Joshua
Jenkins also you got a two-parter here
thank you for the super chats I cried so
much the second time I saw Rocket's
backstory and it broke me quill going
back to Hearth hit me really hard
that was unexpected and beautiful for
sure
Joshua Jenkins loss continues it with
Cosmo was a huge part of the show too
and we see groots Planet 2 and where
Thanos created symbiotic monsters yeah
hybrids
I think they I really feel like
this is the best possible conclusion we
could have gotten
feels like it to me it like that I've
I've come to this idea lately especially
seeing these climactic third
installments of stuff where like certain
things feel like the sequel or the end
or whatever it is and certain things
feel like a sequel or an end and this
felt like the sequel the end it's it
feels like an actual thought out Trilogy
Where I'm sure it's changed along the
ways of when it came to sitting down and
writing bless you but it really feels
like the story
similar to I mean I think they want to
do a little bit more The Dark Knight
trilogy but this seemed like a direction
of this is the story you wanted like
there's something to the words of volume
that make the most sense to me uh
because it's always sounded like a play
on on on the idea of like tracks you
know uh of music but this especially
with the things you're pointing out here
like with quill going back home to Earth
you know that was something that I think
in a trailer one of our trade reactions
I was saying like this might be the
first the movie where I imagine quill
might actually go home yeah you know
because we haven't seen that happen like
you're thinking about character arcs and
they really they really panned that out
and even with Drax even even made the
whole Drax becoming Dumber work yeah
yeah something that I thought was kind
of annoying like did become like why'd
they just do that especially in
Guardians too like a lot of people love
that one scene when Drax and mantis are
talking with each other but he doesn't
he said that's like one part where he's
necessary with saving mantis but
that is still a great for me with that
movie they do dumb him up a lot in that
film and he spends so much time just
scream laughing yeah through most
interactions but they did a great job uh
with it well yeah it feels like it
naturally was supposed to me it feels
like one of those things where like even
though these weren't all conceived of at
the same time they certainly were made
over a decade or more like it feels like
this was where this was headed and this
feels like the natural conclusion and it
feels right well I want to use this as a
moment too to with Heather gears Super
Chat thank you heather can you talk more
about why I think it's what a
well-structured conclusion is I mean she
she's saying happy Saturday lovely gents
Heather we love you always seen your
comments always fresh out of the movie
and wow what a film excellent
performances all around possible hot
take this was my favorite Guardian
soundtrack and the thing with the
soundtrack two of another great because
I'm a fan of good bookends it's a fan of
good looking
um with the first needle drop being
the what is that goddamn song called
Radiohead no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no
hey
what the matter what is it come and get
your love come and get you over there
I'm trying to get to the course yeah
yeah because then he plays it all the
way again at the yeah then he plays it
in the post credits which was kind of
special yeah yeah for those to be the
book ends of the needle tracks uh I
think is awesome to show the full circle
that's something a lot of people aren't
thinking about like that is the first
needle drop you know absolutely and the
needle drops are a signature staple of
of the Guardians movies yeah when I love
to like like yeah that's such a great
thing because those are some of the
things that make Peter as an Earthling
like those those are the things that
remind you the most of Earth because it
did strike me when you said that about
like oh yeah we we haven't seen him go
home and and in this third movie they
make a point of him being like I haven't
been out back to Earth why would I know
such and such and such a thing cars for
example whereas yeah like the the music
sort of keeps the earthliness alive
within the character but yeah I think I
might agree with you this at least I
want to revisit them now in hindsight of
part three but this uh at face value
both times I think is my favorite thus
far like I I love the the flow and the
song Choices and yeah the stuff I am
familiar with and the stuff I wasn't
familiar with I thought was really
nicely chosen
ah
I even like when unless I'm missing
something but like how it starts off
with rocket who's actually like kind of
into them he was into the music now well
that's the thing throughout the movie
he's like kind of like bopping along and
along and even when they reunited he's
on the mission at the end like he's
singing along with the song that Peter
puts on because before he in Guardians 2
he doesn't really give into it yeah
where he's like we're trying to play
because that's what Peter wants you know
yeah but it's like when he and I think
it's inside a day
see and that's what I think is really
great too is with Guardians 2
then we gotta move on uh recordings too
um with guardians too
this user right here all right so
favorite line I'm done running thank you
Melvin for the Super Chat bring it back
to Rocket
um with guardians too it did strike me
as odd when I watched you see it wasn't
until I
I think weirdly watching the trailer for
volume 3 and then watching Guardians 2
Made Me Love made me understand
something about Guardians 2 more was
because in Guardians 2 to go from
guardians Winter Gardens Too rocket to
to be so much of a like he's just
sabotaging like like in ways it's
frustrating like with getting the
batteries from The Sovereign like it was
it's frustrating he's like such a dick
and I'm like I thought we kind of went
through this already in the first movie
like what's going on man yeah this was
the arc yeah and but then you're seeing
you know they do establish it and I
think the movie makes it hasn't get
better as the film progresses especially
with the relationship he forms with
yondu
however when you watch this movie you're
like it makes a hundred percent sense
why nowadays at a new form family why
he's just now trying to sabotage the
[__] out of it yeah yeah and so I think
it does like I really feel like if you
watch all three
the thing is I do think you've got to
watch because of a nukemora you got to
include Infinity war end game
yeah
you should make a cut where you can just
supplement I should make like a
condensed Guardians cut of everything
from uh infinity war and end game that
you could put between two and three
um yeah
Ryan gigg uh I understand thank you so
much it's not being talked about enough
how much Chris Pratt sold the
desperation of Starla trying to save
rocket had me in tears absolutely I
think Chris hey Cody lead to the chat
what's up buddy yo yo um I think
I think that when it comes to Chris
Pratt like he was one of the things I
said was one like one of the standouts
to me in this movie and I I feel like he
kind of gets taken for all these [__]
that's a big Super Chat thank you so
much
wow thanks um Aiden uh whoa this is just
something big like that pops in thank
you
um
regain your composure correct Chris
Chris Pratt desperation the strong Camp
you do this every single day
no thanks for the thousand dollars I
appreciate it anyway
back to my rant about Toby Maguire
I think somebody talked about it enough
how much Chris Pratt sold the destroy I
I think Chris Pratt's reputation has
weirdly been
um it's got a bit of a cloud over it
[Laughter]
in the public discourse is an odd one
and I don't I really don't care about
I really don't care about his religious
beliefs I honestly don't I don't think
he's a good act I think I think he's a
really good actor but over the years I
have found you know it harder to because
scrap as an actor I loved and then
suddenly he became
I don't really believe him anymore sure
to
because that's and it's kind of the way
it was for me and even like Guardians 2
of where I was like
gosh she's just mainly Chris Pratt it
still looks like his best role for me
but I still like Guardians one I'm like
that's that's a character that's
Star-Lord yeah you know whoever the hell
Owen is in the [__] Jurassic world
yeah but here I'm like this is a per I
thought he'd overall gave a great
performance he's a great lead you see
have Star-Lord as a real leader here he
doesn't completely lose the boyish charm
that we love about him in certain key
moments uh he could still be like that
lied about I'm not 50. that's a great
life great delivery yeah yeah a great
deflection a great delivery for a great
joke yeah are you about to die yeah
it's funny because you you're gonna
wonder why when you're wondering my
mantis is saying that and then if he
registers it
um so funny and but then yeah in that
scene more than just being a crying
scene like there's a whole variety of
emotions going on there but I love
the the intensity that he has like when
when they go to get the car yeah in the
[__] car like he he finds the humor
but there is an intensity that he has
right down to when they push the guy out
the window and drag him down and he's
like the ship's coming like there's just
such a different type of demeanor and
seriousness about Star-Lord in this that
naturally gets there like when they're
trying to get the um I forgot the name
of the plate on the guy's head yeah
while the water's coming he's like
whoever's in the ship hit the brakes
pull pull heart like the way he's doing
is not like I'm being funny Star-Lord
right now and I love this seriousness
that Chris Pratt has in this movie and
it's very believable and yet he doesn't
only play it's serious and stoic
throughout yeah you know yeah it's a
well-rounded performance it feels mature
it feels like this character we've
watched has grown and two I really liked
especially I realized it through him but
everybody kind of has it is they've also
developed this really great dynamic in
those moments like when he's prepping
The Shield bypass things of like just
the Tactical speak like I really bought
them as a Tactical Unit who pulls off
missions rather than just you know like
fun-loving you know gang of Misfits
that's a really great Point that's a
really really great Point like
especially when they're trying to get
back to the high evolutionaries base
yeah
um yeah that was solid yeah when they're
just like coordinating with each other
and yeah like you know and and two like
those moments where he has to think on
his feet like in the orgo Corp sequence
where he just goes off on uh Nathan
Fillion at first like even moments like
that are just like so well played and
you can really feel like oh man he's
thinking on his feet you know I do the
one part about it about the Guardians
franchise that I do think it's a little
bit lost
is
um they keep saying like for the
Guardians of the Galaxy right they keep
saying that but we've never seen them
really be hired to be a guardian of the
galaxy yeah we saw them have to protect
those batteries at one point but most
important but they wanted to trade that
to get nebula yeah it's nebula and then
most of part two is just spent with ego
and stuff like that and I mean like well
they have the nowhere place in in the
planet they're not really like doing
guarding of the Galaxy [__] yeah it
seems like they're they're chilling out
here until a distress signal happens to
reach them or some kind of thing happens
to fall in their laps and the most I
guess it connected to the overall Galaxy
they feel would be an Infinity war end
game because those are Galactic Stakes I
love how there have been people have
been coming into the stream who are just
coming advocacy in the movie yeah
benefit of dude on Saturday right and
well I know he's like right now
yeah that's right yeah what did you
think Chase let us chase he's loved it
he loved it
um
uh I legit the film Point says I legit
thought what time is it what's up
Spencer uh it is 205 p.m Pacific
Standard time uh in like five more
minutes we should probably if I'm a
restaurant have to turn off the super
chats uh because yeah we gotta make sure
we end on time
I got a meeting to do film punch I legit
thought High evolutionary just got space
Botox
well that's why I looked weird also a
student color of his powers are similar
to King do you think there's a
connection
I always just think of the Power Stone I
always just think of like power and and
you know the the
harnessing there of the dominion over
Powers represented by purple
I don't know I feel like Jameson just
likes purple or especially if you're
kind of bullshitted his way through the
whole infinity stone thing
that definitely tracks
I mean you know it at least seems like
it's a physical power that uh that he
has but but yeah I mean purple just
looks cool
I feel like if if the movie was rated R
James Gunn would have made the high
evolutionary effect look more disturbing
on the face stretch probably yeah I
could have made that look grotesque yeah
and I think the the actual ripping up of
his face probably would have been even
worse I don't think they would have said
it from I think they would have shown it
okay
I like it actually I do like it from
behind but I think they they would have
shown it yeah who's Taylor Strong's
Cameo do you know
we caught uh Tiffany Smith Coy told me
what it was damn
and apparently Tara Strong's Cameo was
supposed to be Miley Cyrus
funny but uh they replaced her flicking
real thank you so much buddy what's your
name here Jess here it looks sad I don't
like how this makes me feel
oh yeah blue filters I love delivery did
save a lot of that I'm being terrible I
think he was great and and I did I don't
know I loved I loved the way they
pitched his just just in this isolated
situation I loved the way they pitched
him as this this child who has been
given this great purpose and who is you
know like kind of capable of carrying it
but also is very much trying to process
just everyone above him giving him
orders and stuff and you know what I
love no one's really talked about
Jennifer Holland
I know who gets a lot of unnecessary
[__] yeah especially when friggin Nathan
Fillion is here like and all the other
people that James Gunn puts in his
movies constantly there's something
about when someone uses their wife
though yeah people gets the most
particularly uh yeah
I mean which is funny to me about
Jennifer Holland because we were we
watched we reacted a peacemaker on this
channel and I had no clue Jennifer
Holland we I don't think either of us
did we didn't know for a while that that
this person was even in a relationship
with James gone
we were just like this girl This Woman's
great yeah
she's amazing he's great yeah and I mean
like the part she plays isn't like he
made her Gamora or something like that
you know and and it's so small
really fun she plays that really well uh
Tara Strong was Mainframe who is the
floating head ravager that looks uh you
know oh yeah the floating helmet oh
that's cool yeah so sorry Miley Cyrus
I think Guardians is the best Trilogy in
the MCU yeah there's not even a question
to me about it uh I think I think it's
better than all the than spider I think
it's a Trilogy better than the
Spider-Man ones I think it's a Trilogy
better than Iron Man truly like you
could easily look at one of those in
each of the students
sure sure you know I think Captain
America is probably the second strongest
yeah for sure you know people argue
about the first one but the other two
are pretty agreeable for sure there you
go this was what is a Guardians Captain
America Iron Man Spider-Man yeah I feel
like Spider-Man is like really saved as
a Trilogy by no way
um
Daniel ruska thank you so much oh Peter
cool hi I'm Patrick Swayze I love his
delivery on that line too because it
sounds like he's coming up with that in
the moment that's the best kind of line
delivery for a joke like that yeah and I
I won like that seems like the kind of
joke that would be written but part of
me wonders if it was in any way an
improv just because it is so well
delivered that like in that spirit
the carrot guy bit was so funny
guys it looks like a carrot
dude Zoe Saldana's ruthlessness I don't
know there's something that was so hot
to me about it I loved her in this movie
I thought she was terrific she's like
yeah this one bam I love her hair's all
scuzzed up all the time I don't even I'm
not even sure what Zoe Saldana looks
like without makeup anymore I can't I
can't quite picture it took me a minute
to realize like oh she's just her in
Star Trek I just don't ever really think
of I don't even really remember what she
looks like yeah I really don't and she
hasn't been part of the press tour for
some reason
weird
um I'm assuming it's filming stuff or
she sucks people hate her she's awful
Disney doesn't like she's just so she's
just too busy swimming in her billions
the panda thank you so much again for
being here where was Peter's Master
boost thrusters in the end question that
we brought up earlier no idea especially
when the masting is shown to be a
lifesaver in two movies oh yeah
yeah very excellent question also a
vegetable Planet I would love that yeah
probably in the Marvels also Gamora does
let them put all the suits in that pod
like I painted to enter the second time
because he does berate mantis for like
you put them in the Pod that evacuates
everything once you close it and I'm
like but you're in the scene stuffing
[__] in the Pod you have to know
I mean people blame that that's part of
the guardian's personality like they
they blame whoever said it you know like
so while they all went through with it
they like trusted her that she was
making the right call yeah that's that
tracks yeah it's not defending hers
that's the characters yeah they blame uh
Jordan Garza I'm gonna see your name
again just my opinion but gun showed
alcoholism better in the small time in
the intro than end game did with Thor I
mean it was so Bri something felt kind
of
real about it well yeah because he's
like a a semi-functioning alcoholic and
then later on he just I don't know he
feels like a guy throughout the movie
who is sober after you know a bender in
a way and that thing when they're
setting up the shield bypass and and
he's like man if I hadn't been drinking
like a rocket probably would be fine you
know I might have been able to help and
uh and yeah it was like it was impactful
but it was just enough you didn't need
him to be drinking the whole movie and
make it like a Peter we need an
intervention on you yeah and it could
have backfired a lot the drinking
especially with seeing how rock it
um
because you do get the impression like
maybe if if Star-Lord wasn't drunk he
could have been more vital in helping to
prevent rocket from being this injured
uh but because he does like sober up and
just take responsibility right away like
it does make it more of a personal
moment like it is there's not much of us
it doesn't really carry through with the
rest of the movie yeah the alcoholism
struggle but it's part of his greater
anguish it's just another detail in his
journey and it's not like the point yeah
it's not like we've been watching this
guy struggle with alcohol they're three
moves you know
um God yeah you know what's funny too I
I didn't realize but apparently the when
they're carrying him that is not a real
body that is like a 35 pound dummy yeah
well I was thinking that when I was like
how did they do this did they put him on
strings the trailer I was like dude must
be a wire again or something or maybe
they have some kind of thing they like a
cart they can paint out but yeah
apparently it was like this super
lifelike dummy
um
I have two Ricardo Loza Hernandez
that's a great question about Gamora
actually I want to visit that I have two
questions going forward do you think
this the new information of Guardians
will be entertaining as the previous
roster of Guardians do you feel Adam
Warlock was underused as a new character
to the MCU
um I don't feel like I I I don't know
who would want the job to take on the
next Garden I I don't know who would
possibly want that yeah Mick G
um and I wonder if
I'm sure it's not allowed by any stretch
but I wonder if they did want to
continue Guardians if they wanted to see
if James Gunn could act as producer
which would be wild
so he could be the committee
but I don't see it happening I really
don't what about a version where he
writes more guardians but does not
direct them
I mean you know he seems to I think he
would have to do gar like the thing is
the Guardians of the Galaxy at the end
of the day is very much formulated to
James Gunn's sensibilities
so you can do the guardians galaxy I
just think if you try to do what James
Gunn did you're gonna fail you're gonna
you would have to do a completely
different kind of gene of Guardians of
the Galaxy interpretation in order for
it to work that's why I'm not the
biggest fan of carryover characters
because I'm like there's two associated
with James Gunn
um and they're very much done in the
style of like Sir James Gunn does you
know
um it's rare it's like this is exactly
like and there are people who've said
I've met like I don't and I think even
Nathan Fillion said it like I didn't
like the comics but I love James Gunn's
movies
um and I sometimes that is a sentiment
because he really formulates it to make
it his own and in his voice so I think
if you do the Guardians I think trying
to do you you know another James Gunn
movie you're gonna just shoot yourself
in the foot so don't try uh wait a while
too wait a while and really see how you
can make your own
um because I think the other thing we
don't realize is maybe the talent who is
properly suited to carrying on that
mantle just hasn't Arisen yet sure you
know
do you feel animal cross under uses his
new character in the MCU that's why I
started off talking about John trivia
really talked about thing uh yeah
um
I think that's fine for this movie we'll
see how he progresses within the Marvel
Cinematic Universe itself yeah
um I'm not upset I thought he was lovely
in his Edition and because he's not the
point I think it works uh yeah for the
greater MCU we'll see for the greater
MCU the greater good uh Gamora a
question about
uh yeah we'll visit okay I need a ton of
these uh suits yeah we're two and a half
hours already huh
oh boy
oh boy must conserve energy yes sorry
babarine that's not the Super sassa
three two one am boom I understand the
implications of this action yeah you
guys are getting a a first-hand glimpse
of how it works I'm excited for the
Marvels
I am it's mainly too in this in the
trailers I'm fascinated like it is a
delivery is so good in that trailer I
just see stuff working for the first
time yeah oh God yeah yeah it's so funny
she's she's hilarious I've very curious
I said I like the trailer but I do think
it is an odd trailer and I'm very
curious as to how that movie will yeah
I'm curious with the with the tone and
pacing of it's gonna be like well and
what is really going on aside from like
most of what I grasp is just like okay
when they use their powers they you know
switch and they switch places and they
they teleport and whatnot like yeah John
that's all I got
jolly good
moving on yeah yeah whatever man for
sure yeah just like it it's Marvel agree
like everything Marvel that's how it
works around right because Disney paid
us to say that
I just want I just want to be on their
good list
Yeah man so that we can keep getting
those
free Disneyland passes and free movies
and money delivered by dump truck to our
doorsteps
Michael Mack thank you Michael Mack
Michael Mack hey guys love the movie
performances were great hallway action
scene was awesome if you're not in a
bathroom you're in a hallway that's
where you get your best fight scenes
always cool to see Nathan Philly and pop
up and stuff hey what was your favorite
cameo
probably Nathan Fillion also great
interview with pom big love from
Scotland as always
um thank you I did like that interview
with palm she was really nice uh really
sweet
uh it was funny because I was a koi
introduced uh me to Karen Gillen and I
was I was in this like little circle of
koi and this other people carrying me I
was just like the awkward quiet guy
because I'm like I don't really want to
like
have a conversation I just want to tell
you you did a good job
um but I'm not trying to I feel like at
these events it could be it could be
very easy to fall into I feel like I
don't want ever come across like I'm
trying to network or weasel my way into
a car so like I'm just not I'm not that
comfortable at those kind of events yeah
um but so uh it's just quiet and then
pom Clementi have showed up in the
circle too and I was like do I say
something I'm gonna meet her in a couple
days
uh I don't want to do the whole thing
because she's probably gonna forget that
I said hi to her so I'm just gonna
wait to introduce myself sure
which is super nice though that's good I
mean as long as that's the case I think
any version of this was a good choice I
actually did talk briefly with her about
uh Doctor Who because Matt Smith got
brought up and talked about that
heartbreaking and I did tell her like I
I didn't tear up until that moment where
she did cry and I I really complimented
her work on Oculus as well
um yeah I don't ever try to like Network
at those things you know I just want
there'd always just be like going on the
channel do some reactions to Karen
Gillen yeah she can't fit on camera
she's like eight feet tall he is we
would have to get a short chair
so tall she is very so tall he's quite
tall
even even whatever you know elevation
from shoes for a nice event decide she's
definitely taller than us yeah
definitely even without shoes she could
take us she's a freak that caring yeah
tall freak nine feet tall
what are they putting in the water out
there and Scott throwing net around her
bring her down
cut me a mermaid bring it back and mount
it on the wall
Guardians of the tall Galaxy
oh yeah
that's great uh I liked uh I mean I'm
always happy to see on do so like
Michael Rooker wears that makeup so well
I thought um I thought Aisha got a very
unceremonious death yeah
did we even see it happen
that blows up I guess so yeah
yeah and I guess that's it for the
stopper
except for Adam Adam lives and that's I
mean and that's Elizabeth Debicki I mean
this is a pretty prominent actor so
the panda
[Laughter]
I loved it Jerry too oh thank you I need
this this form herself of course and
thank you the panda I I love you and I
love pandas how do you guys get away
with sure some shirts being designs
without being copyrighted also would you
ever do rejects gaming where do you
where you do gaming streams and stuff I
that has been one of the most
contemplative parts of my life of of
doing that um I wanted to do it with
Jedi Survivor
but then
I don't want to read the chat
I don't think I'd be interactive is the
thing I would be very I have a lot of
coordination I'm a very quiet gamer I
get I get very serious if focused yeah
like I don't want to talk
I don't want to I want to I'm a very
yeah I I I I don't [__] around with that
[__]
um
so
then I but I'd be like put these people
are here I gotta talk uh
oh yeah
um it's hard for the shirt designs uh
that's about my Patriot I don't like I I
often submit ideas because a lot of the
time it's like
like for for The Last of Us shirt was
um you know I obviously came up with the
concept and and then I had like a type
of design of The Last of Us that was
popular that was like I thought it'd be
cool to do a riff on this but make him
like more like Pedro Pascal because the
joke is that's baby Yoda but give it
this color and then I thought of like
what a funny text might be
that we had to like you have to like
change up certain stuff until the point
where they run up by there's a legal
department so they the legal has to run
a they run if they're legal to see it
like okay
yeah I don't know I don't know what the
parameters are but if it was me I'd be
like make it look 100 like Patriot
Pascal at 100 baby Yoda and we're good
but I can't do this yeah so it's it's
all about formulating enough to be
within like
I don't know I I really don't know it's
got to be changed enough to meet a legal
satisfaction and it's got to be like 20
or more different from the original a
lot of the that's why reactions are are
okay especially when you cut them up
because you're transforming it in some
way you know
um and so yeah I but at the end of the
day I have no idea a lot of the things I
pitch get rejected and it's it's really
sad because because I'm like yeah
skeletal
skeletal thank you so much I love you
guys love you love you the love the Love
Fest in here always every day a quarter
if I was phenomenal it was beautiful
times I've seen this movie Magic
Aiden Doherty what a fantastic Super
Chat
hey from Alaska print it out shot money
from underneath
covered in a layer of ice volume 1 was
my favorite Marvel movie
volume 3 just became my favorite comic
book movie of all time
when do you think the legendary
Star-Lord will return I did not think
this would be the most asked question
either what did you think of Adam
Warlock you were disappointed huh or uh
or
um uh uh uh uh or like what do you think
star of the world will return it's great
to see the love for Star-Lord back
because I really feel like Chris Frank
it's such a bad rap
and in a way that I do find unfair
because
well it depends on who you ask
I mean for me Chris Pratt I used to be
very enthusiastic and then he became you
know he reached Peak Hollywood
saturation and since then I've been like
kind of ambivalent about Chris Pratt and
in the movie like this that's a good
opportunity for him to really grab me
and remind me what I did like when I was
enthusiastic don't feel like he's doing
anything where he's shoving [__] down
people's throats
you know like maybe he's part of a
church that's [__] up or maybe he's
not I don't know all right maybe he
voted for sure I don't know like I
don't know but in terms of like
an actor and and doing a person who
shows up to do his job and as far as
what he puts out there to the public as
I'm like I think he's fine in that
regard right so I do feel like he gets a
bit of an unfair rep uh
so yeah it's nice to see like a lot of
love and and and wanting more Star-Lord
again especially after this movie where
I did think he did his best work as
Star-Lord yeah uh great performance I I
do think it's Avengers Infinity war and
Avengers can't one of those two where
he's going to return it would be
interesting to get a solo film I don't
know what that would be and I feel like
a big part of the charm of Star-Lord is
him
being paired off with other people yeah
or just with people to uh butt up
against and create friction with yeah
and I think it'd be kind of weird like
would the Standalone be it would be like
it's like when you do like X-Men Origins
what was like well you're just gonna get
a new Ensemble of a bunch of other ex
mutants yeah
Professor X leading them this is going
to be Wolverine it's gonna basically be
another Guardians movie Yes
Star-Lord and the what or Star-Lord like
we know what solo Adventure is there to
be told like is time growing up as the
ravagers and watching him sneak up in
boxes yeah yeah all that stuff made
about him being small and easy to cram
into tight spaces
um but yeah I think he will I like how
they did keep the door open
um
I don't I I have no idea what it what it
would be and and
I I would like I mean part of the big
appeal of it like part of the heart and
soul of the franchise like is Rocket and
Groot sure but like I think rocket and
Star-Lord specifically them two together
is such an integral part and this movie
really showed that that these it's been
primarily their two stories you know
yeah so um well because they both have a
like their own separate degrees of like
childhood trauma to do and not that the
other characters don't but it's the most
highlighted and it feels the longest
deepest running for each of them yeah
whereas everybody else has their
struggles and has their you know core
traumas and wants and things like that
but I feel like yeah they anchor it with
the most sort of dimension
hey I would like to revisit the whole
MCU ranking I just do feel like the
James Gunn side of of MCU is vastly
different yeah you know yeah which team
do you like better Avengers or Guardians
I mean it's kind of unfair like you kind
of keep adding to the roster of Avengers
because it's just like who has a movie
they're an adventure yeah you know I
mean I feel more uh I feel a more like
jovial kind of like familial buddy love
for the Guardians team just because of
the consistency of what they are
and like you know the I think the
Avengers as a team is fun and
interesting and like it's always great
to have the different interactions and
the frictions and the reasons to make
them fight each other and then
ultimately get back together but I don't
know there's just such an emotionality
that runs through the Guardians in
particular that is less like it's always
based on whatever they're up against but
I feel like The Avengers I connect to
them in relation to what they're up
against rather than just them as a team
yeah because also too we're so used to
seeing all of them off on their own and
they occasionally team upwards the
Guardians the whole thing is they're a
team all the time
let me just do one last check here then
we're just going to focus on the chat
here also yes more cragula always more
cragulant we didn't talk about cragling
at all I know I'm a man no one cares to
ask about Cracklin James Gunn always
casting his brother uh last stream Lab
of the day oh Let's Do It Let's Do It
Let's Do It Let's Do It
um Ronin unchanned
hey Greg and John I love the last shots
of all three Guardians movies connect to
Rocket versus they're flying ship flying
away into the forever and beautiful sky
second rocket crying out of Hope third
rocket happy finding some peace within
himself
absolutely yeah oh that's a great
assessment sure enough
and two the moments where they make
rocket cry are always very impactful
when he's when he's like weeping in the
room with all the cages I was like
I feel it grabs the other raccoons
accepts the fact that he is a raccoon
yeah what I love too that
would pulled out of Heaven it's on that
most human aspect like he the the heart
rate monitor goes flat when he breathes
that sigh of relief of like I can stop
now I can go to heaven and then he gets
pulled out immediately he's like I'm not
a raccoon which is like a perfect
Earthbound line for him
and uh
so many beautiful little tie rounds and
motifs
um yeah the this the little raccoons man
those are adorable heartbreaking yeah
she's like those are tying a raccoon's
really that tiny One Rewards
damn yeah and most mammals are unless
you're dealing with the Biggins but it's
so small even dogs start a little Thai
potato
oh yeah I love I love that
I love that part a lot yeah I do love I
think it's really Catholic when they're
all killing him but someone brought up
uh I appreciate that point though about
rocket it's I'm excited for Rockets to
return
and Groot to say more I am Groot lines
and then for them to translate
everything into English yeah the
audience here into English like I've
done English into uh into into actual
words Beyond I am Groot
um
ready for this John are You Ready hey
are you ready for this are you hanging
on the edge of your seat see I adjusted
that boom oh wow separate a tad John you
did it separate a tad we're done with
this with the Super Chips yeah man we're
all caught up thank you to everyone in
the trip to Super chess we're gonna
stand here for just a few more minutes
catching up here
um but yeah cragland I thought was great
uh I thought you'd get a little bit more
time
his moment was probably the most like
on ceremonies I mean it's it's kind of
requisite in the way it's like you know
he's he's trying to get the arrow down
and then all he needs is that last
little encouragement from yondu to do it
from your heart and that brings it all
together you know like it's a little uh
familiar but because I thought we'd have
more like especially after getting
Yonder than he gets he gets to inherit
the arrow that we I thought we'd get a
little bit more like understanding and
insight into who craglin is sure instead
of just like a cowboy guy but then um
you know James good it was like I don't
want people to accuse us of nepotism
you're in all my movies already playing
multiple characters yeah I mean did he
and I couldn't catch in the credits did
he do the mocap for Rocket again because
I think he usually does the rocket mode
cap I'm not sure but Riley Cooper gets
all the credit yeah yeah so there was
that
um what are the points I like I like
growing quite a bit and cragula big all
big ups for cragula we talked about the
F-bomb okay we talked about that what
other things did we not talk about I
want to make sure we just squeeze them
in here in the final stretch
um
so we talked about everything right I
feel like we talked about most
everything I mean they're like isolated
moments but I mean we talked about I
mean we haven't really spent much time
talking about the high evolutionaries
various Creations but I feel like the
main four are the you know are the point
of that yeah his little kids and stuff
like that we get another kids in cages I
appreciate it on counter Earth how they
had really developed their own language
instead of just another planet where
everyone speaks English and they didn't
subtitle it which I think is good too
yeah which I mean obviously for for the
point of the scene and I love that they
used that that the whole both with them
with the kids later like the language
barrier is the thing how do we
communicate this
and uh and yeah I don't know that added
like a nice realistic like set of stakes
and and yes like sometimes just the need
to communicate can be so intense
and two I love that nebula was just so
refreshed by that drink they gave him I
think it was interesting too
um oh Cosmo we haven't talked much about
Cosmo
not that there's much to talk about hey
I put that dog through hell with those
ships at the end ah Cosmo's a good dog
Cosmo is very powerful I thought Cosmo
was very cute and and and probably
written the voice of James Gunn's dog uh
who passed away a couple years ago
uh I think I think it was when filming
The Suicide Squad that actually let him
take time offset to go back home and see
his dog because they had to put him down
oh and they even designed
um there's like a part of like Rocket's
teeth and and Groot
uh I think it's Rocket's eyes and teeth
is actually modeled after his dog oh oh
that's I did not know that that is
beautiful I believe so I believe so
um the panda that is a great point about
drax's nipples I mean like not only did
the jumpsuit not match his skin tone but
also I mean that those jumpsuits are not
made of the most like soft material
obviously they got to be sturdy so his
nipples must have been on fire this
whole movie uh I I don't
uh I want to out this person in case
people like react weirdly do it the uh I
have one friend who you guys might have
seen this channel but they they were
they were like they seemed like really
disappointed by the lack of ravagers in
this movie okay because of the setup of
all the ravagers in the post-credits
scene for
I thought a lot of like the post-credit
[__] and Guardians 2 was for humor yeah
like all the different ravagers they saw
too were just like fun cameos like they
had Michelle yo here in in part two who
I was like there's no way you're gonna
bring Michelle yo back because I think I
think that would be way too confusing
especially now she's in the shangshi
movies yeah I think yeah way too
confusing I've already done this with
Gemma Chan once but Gemma Chan's at
least like joust in Blue makeup in in
Captain Marvel you know yeah yeah yeah
it's like a totally different look and
that character's dead you know also that
yeah so that yeah that's a very
different scenario
um versus I don't know why we've never
done this this whole time John
oh and do the enlarged thing
instead of like sit over there
I mean it's just it's just a different
version but also yes it is much nicer
much bigger you know it's much more
intimate easier to control the space too
yeah
I was trying to figure out if there was
a way to like do two camera capture
devices and then just split in and happy
you can't do a trim unfortunately
I tried you could do certain things have
crop functions but we'd have to look
into it yeah I was trying to figure it
out last night
um but anyways yeah two cameras so
um yeah that was it what I forgot what
we're talking about
uh you know if that's the table too
I thought Dave Bautista for sure was
gonna die in this movie I really thought
for I was a hundred percent convinced
Dave Bautista was gonna die
somebody wanted one of the words on
headless Group which seemed he's like a
direct thing nod did you guys catch in
the poker scene when Cosmo and Cracklin
are there that the per one the person
who tries to have the orb to yeah yeah
yeah yeah
give the orb two in the first movie
um
I thought Sloan did a good job here I
thought he was actually better here than
he was in the last card I found in the
Guardians too he's kind of distracting
yeah yeah and I bet I think now he's
personal thing now he's like familiar
with the world yeah so I think and also
working with James Gunn now a couple of
times yeah that I think it was a little
bit easier for uh for him to adjust to
this movie yeah it seems like and I I
thought like I wasn't even thinking
about him and I was like oh that's right
of course he might show up and uh yeah I
thought he did fine I thought he did a
fine job setting up the next leg of the
mission basically
the creepy human I I think there was
something that James it's funny you okay
so my wife very sensitive animal deaths
you're bringing up creepy animal
humanoids and I thought this was a
fascinating Choice
um because
you use I was like before when the movie
right before the movie started Elena
John and I said okay so because I was
like I have to like Shield my wife from
uh any animal death I was like okay so
there's a turtle and then like Lyle and
the others right yeah I was like is
there any more he's like do you care
about
the war Pig
I was like
dude
and then when I was watching the movie
and then because my wife cried so early
on and then when the war Pig finally
came on screen
I was like that's kind of a disturbing
imagery and the implications that they
converted a pig into this yeah
and I had just watched I had already
like walked her out of the theater with
the Lila death scene and then brought
her back in when rocket was escaping in
the ship
and then moments before the war Pig got
his head torn off like moments before
because I just remembered how the war it
took me I couldn't remember how the war
Pig died I was and then I was like the
scene was coming up I suddenly
remembered and and then I I turned to
her and I was like do you care if that
thing dies and she's like yeah
I died terribly she had glasses I
thought yeah I thought of bee pop two
from TMNT
um she had glasses on until it just like
smacked her glasses and I didn't want
her to see it and I didn't catch it I
was like oh I totally for guys like
carrying this Pig's head around for like
a few minutes yeah or for at least a few
shots yeah
um so uh yeah that that
um
that was was interesting to me is like
and then what's the other one who's with
war Pig what is that something falcon or
bird what the [__] is that I couldn't
tell yeah because it's got like a beak
but I couldn't tell if it was a bird or
a lizard or something
um because yeah that
the implications of that or even like
the octopus is like well these are still
animals
that was your voice okay yeah um I
couldn't tell to the one in Ant-Man yeah
oh okay um why not that's cool I
couldn't I couldn't tell
um
not gonna tell what am I trying to say
what I found interesting okay yeah we
gotta have this room soon what about
interesting what was that the
I I wonder if in an R-rated movie if
James Gunn still would have the way how
he leaned into starro yeah it like this
is a tragic thing for sorrow in a lot of
ways because Charo is like kind of not
evil I mean he does some like [__] up
things but he's not he's not he's not
that evil
um
yeah victim of circumstance
and these and so is every animal here
that is portrayed as being an evil
villain that they have to kill right in
this movie like every single creature
they're fighting at the end there's an
underlying context of these are animals
who were converted yes and but the movie
can't have you gotta have some type of
like celebration of awesome finale
action because if you're too aware of
that in the hallway fight then you're
like well it's kind of [__] up man
ever heard these abused animals right I
think they yeah they try to bridge that
Gap by being like these are tragic
Creations however they I mean they
freaking they call them the hell spawn
and they are clearly I don't know I mean
they're like organized enough that
they're not just killing all the time
but it seems like their main function is
to harness that aggression he's been
trying to build out of the rest of them
so yeah I don't know yeah it is an
interesting ethical question I do
appreciate it at least that the movie at
different times touches on again just
like the complication of that even as
they are saving the animals someone get
attacked by the monkey them at the end
having to save these you know settlers
from the Stampede and it's like do you
ever feel bad for them yeah but these
people can't defend themselves and I
think I guess that's kind of the line
they're riding is these are just souped
up war machines and that's kind of their
only function totally so it lets you off
that way but it is you know the same
ethical question of like this poor Pig
though you know these poor creatures
that were created this way
isn't it I don't know it gets you
talking because it's an interesting
array of things
and I do very much appreciate that they
make a point of saving all the animals
it just seems right also whoever said
that in the chat I I didn't think of it
at the time but I could see some Judge
Dredd in that uh Stallone suit there
I wouldn't put it past James gun to
Homage that
no comment
what does it come
yes thousand percent
wait let me correct one million let me
direction to John one million percent
you're more than me yeah you're a
million percent more than I am at
whatever it is whatever it is you are a
million percent more I'm even better at
Guitar yes you are uh
I mean you're more about music songs
yeah see tell me John
[Laughter]
I mean yeah in a lot of ways you are you
are much more advanced in your operating
I'm better than you at being empathetic
towards others emotions at all times no
I'm I'm not good at that I hate better
than you at always seeing the optimistic
side and things
that's right man
so I really need you to get better than
yourself
figuring out how to set up live streams
yeah yeah yeah if it wasn't I mean I I
like most of what I know I've learned
from you
yeah
so anyway
I'm better I support these statements
wholesale yeah oh you are and and it's
good to be reminded of this periodically
just so that I know my place please do
please do yeah all right guys where are
we ending this dream I'd love to check
it to see like where we ended it at I
wonder what our Peak concurrent viewers
were at oh goody let's let's find out
oh that's that that line did get me I
don't think it was my favorite line
necessarily but that whole like there is
no God that's why I stepped in was like
that was a great yellow line I recommend
that yell live because it seems like oh
that just slipped out of all moments for
then a a like a righteous Mutiny to
happen I was like yeah you earned that
when they all put up the blasters I was
like I mean this isn't gonna work but
also I yeah totally guys yeah homeboy
totally let that [__] slip yeah that was
great yeah oh and yeah and they're so
again like whatever you do to get those
actors at that point where it feels like
something that was just blurted out it's
uh beautiful
alrighty guys well we're gonna call this
a day I want to say uh thank you so much
for being here love all you
um thanks to John for introducing Greg
to Doctor Who do you remember the day
John you sat me down and said hey I'm
introducing you to Dr Greg listen up
this is my friend the dog
that's right man
recommended research thing that we're
like we should cover Doctor Who yeah it
wasn't sat me down and said I'm
introducing you it wasn't upon the the
idea of like maybe we should do watch
alongs from patreon and then us both I
think have the idea of Doctor Who's
massive yeah let's do it no I I I yeah
I'm glad I was able to connect you to my
friend I did it John you introduced me
to doctor who couldn't be happier that's
I know it's your favorite show that we
cover here and I'm better than you in
every way John you are that's why you're
gonna be at Flappers tomorrow at 5 p.m
in Burbank and you all should come and
buy a shirt too yeah buy a shirt get
some me undies pants and while you're at
it download Star Trek Fleet command yes
please do that and hey get yourself some
G fuels as well
alrighty guys thank you so much for
being here before you head out if you
can leave a like that'd be incredible
um this was a lot of fun let's say bye
to everyone John bye Jenny Bye Hannah
love you too bye Ahmed by the Skywalker
radio Zolo one eye Chow Bros Iqbal
no Chanel Chase Daisy Johnson oh quake
look how tiny we are
you know you could just make the oh
Christine you're gonna return
that's what I'd like to hear
Christine
this the stream is about you guys now
yeah look at that you guys oh look at
that you guys you guys are the stars of
the video now well we're saying bye
guillerme Kia so then bye Leia Ariana
Grande
oh that's a nice beard and glasses
combination grade three thanks buddy my
ramen noodles
tins thanks tins or tins
waving right back
it's like playing a gallica yeah
all right for real we're gonna take off
now be well stay sexy on that note